good morning everybody Welcome to
counselors my fellow councilors
um staff and our presenters from Great
South and the tiny homes people
and also Welcome to our youth council
rep Paris good to have you here this
morning this is a topic that will be
very important for our future
um this is a long-term plan workshop on
housing everybody I'll just remind
people and for the benefit of those on
live stream that counselors may have
views on the housing matters we're
discussing today they already have may
have some ideas about the right answers
but this is not a decision-making Forum
workshops are for the collecting of
information the fleshing out of air
knowledge on the particular issues a
chance for discussion and Gathering more
than our existing knowledge
that means we need to take a great deal
of care
that what we do or say doesn't look like
we have already made our decisions
before we have considered all the
relevant information and evidence
anything that is discussed today there
may be possibly a preference arrived at
but this only becomes a decision once
made at a council meeting where all the
relevant decision-making information
will be presented so this counselors is
very much a chance
um for us and their menophena were
representatives to discuss matters
public consultation will likely follow
engagement is always open
um and I'll just remind those on live
stream and welcome to those on live
stream that the con the engagement is
always open on our let's talk platform
the link to that is in the description
below the live stream video
so I'll just ask for any apologies
chair I've just heard one text it
through from Reverend Cox you said an
unexpected issue come up thank you very
much
thank you and I've got Nigel rear and
Barry
see
okay
at this point we will get underway
Rhiannon and Jonathan I believe the
first presentation is yours yep I'll
um kick off
so
um as councilor sopa says this is an ltp
Workshop so for the conversation today
um this morning we're going to hear from
Great South or Beyond 2025 about the
work that's been going on in the housing
work stream
um and as well as some results from some
work that council's been doing around
the effectiveness of the district plan
in relation to housing and then there's
an opportunity for a discussion about
what would success look like from your
perspective in the region before we hear
from
um
some people for about tiny homes and the
opportunities that they might present so
that will be the end then of the public
part of the workshop and then in the
afternoon there's the opportunity to
discuss what role Council can and does
play in the area of housing
um in terms of the long-term plan so
really this Workshop is intended then to
inform asset and activity plans and
identify any strategic projects that
councilors may want to take forward
so that's just a reminder then on the
agenda before we um
get right into it I'll welcome Bobby up
she's going to talk us through these
results and I'm just going to work out
where her slides are
foreign
[Music]
so you can hear me just in case people
don't know me
um so look my role here is that I'm the
Project Lead for a project called Beyond
2025 Southland so what I'd like to do is
just run through the housing part of
that and I'll we're due back on the 11th
of May to go through the whole project
okay
um so probably you need to strap in
because it's quite a bit of information
coming up here
which reflects how complex that how
important this issue is so we've really
tried to get lots of different
perspectives and that's why you're going
to be hearing about housing from lots of
different contexts
so we're going to look back in terms of
understanding what research has happened
and a couple of key pieces of work we're
going to try and understand now in terms
of the impact on different parts of
their community and from different
perspectives
and then we'll look forward in terms of
trying to understand what the future
demand picture looks like and what are
the things that are going to influence
that
okay so just in case you're not sure
what Beyond 2025 South and is
it's the long-term leans over the just
transitions work streams and we've
called it Beyond 2025 Southland
and it's also the refresh of the
regional development strategy source
okay so two different things
that end up in one document
so call Beyond 2025 Southland
which talks about moving forward in
terms of new Pathways for the region
we were at we have 22 research inputs
almost complete and the plan write-up is
underway and obviously we're still doing
quite a lot of consultation with lots of
people so this is a plan for people but
it's also like a big jigsaw puzzle in
terms of putting lots of people's work
together to make sense
let me know if I'm going too fast
through this but I've got quite a few
slides
okay so in terms of where we're at with
the project we are here in April
so we're working through the councils
ewe and others are just socializing
Concepts leading up to a workshop with
you guys on the 11th of May we will
present you with some of the the key
findings and get your feedback
and then on the 17th of May the draft
plan goes for the designers
so we're working towards a launch date
of 28th of June
so this date fits in where central
government elections coming up because
of course this report being part of just
transitions it's managed by Envy
so we've just sort of got that time
frame to work within so she's pretty
tight
so in terms of what and how we've been
trying to develop the plan we've been
following a process so think of this as
a way to make sure that the people who
are involved in certain parts are
so lots of different
pillars thinking of looking forward in
terms of environment and climate change
and diversification of the economy but
also acknowledging that right now
there's a whole lot of challenges for
our business sector and remember we've
got Fourteen and a half thousand
businesses 3 300 Farms
and of course the one I'm going to talk
about today is housing
the resources and infrastructure pillar
is really important because it talks
about making sure that our foundations
are there to enable us to develop or to
be what we want to be so we don't have
that strong Foundation I will struggle
so housing transport digital and energy
are key things
radio so the housing work stream had
three different uh Focus points it was
to look at insights and data to inform
evidence-based decision making
it was to ensure there was a coordinated
Regional approach in Innovative thinking
and it was to look at quality of housing
so we work this out from understanding
what lots of other people were already
doing and trying to find where there
were gaps
so into it now in terms of I'm gonna
there's two or three slides per piece of
research
and I'll just whip through pretty
quickly so in terms of the Desktop
review
that was undertaken at the very
beginning of the process and that had a
purpose to just review what had been
done to make sure we didn't duplicate
but to see what we could build on so 21
documents were reviewed and we talked to
a few key groups such as Southland Home
Trust the community housing group in
Stuart Island Senior Housing
so what they found was that there are
significant constraints to both home
ownership and rentals across the
district and in terms of affordability
availability and quality
there's a lack of housing diversity in
terms of typology of housing based on
residents desire
and Council planning rules are adding to
the challenges of increasing housing
Supply as well as lack of Builders and
sub trades to complete the work so
remember this was done in the past and
just keep that in mind as we look at
what we've found out recently
so in terms of what some of the key
findings
um you know there's opportunity across
the region for housing renewal
intensification and purpose built
particularly for the Aging population
the other thing to note is that these
reports cannot be compared easily
because they were all made for different
purposes so it's not apples with apples
so you've just got to take them for what
they are
so in terms of the gaps the research
showed that we didn't understand
all of the demand and we didn't know a
lot about our housing stock in terms of
age and quality
we didn't understand seasonal employment
and the impact on housing
uh there were issues around social
emergency housing back then which is
still the case today but we needed more
details
and we didn't understand how future
growth projections would impact housing
so that's what the Desktop review showed
back then so we've addressed a lot of
that with the work we're recently done
okay so number two was a key piece of
work that was undertaken through Great
South called the Southland housing
analysis report
so it had a it wanted to take housing to
the next step to try and understand what
the challenges were and the key thing
here is that the insights do line up
with a lot of the other work so we're
all talking the same here
so in terms of peer-to-peer
accommodation with covert we had a bit
of relief there
our workforce planning is going to be
really important to understand how to
meet large industry needs
and there's a flow on impact which we've
definitely seen based on seasonal
employment as well
the third point is around growing
population of elderly who are looking
for smaller warmer homes definitely a
key thing that came up across lots of
pieces of work we'll talk about that
mismatch and housing Zone and an
increase in rental and house purchase
prices demand for social housing and the
last point which is is quite interesting
for our region because of their large
Geographic scale was that we've got
increasing numbers of commuters and uh
both ways coming into main centers but
also traveling out and around for work
and you could argue why that's happening
um but it's probably around availability
of housing work opportunities
Etc
okay so that that report also said that
at that point we were 1659 houses short
to effectively house the population and
that was based on a population of 104
400.
so what's happened since then is that
demand has been less than expected so we
had that that thing called covert so the
population growth was subdued
the other thing that's happened is that
building of houses has been faster than
was anticipated
however I'm going to show you soon that
current feedback from people real estate
agents and businesses all indicate that
there's a shortage of quality housing to
meet demand
Okay the third bit is around the housing
strategy which was undertaken by the
Southland community housing group and
ICC
that focused on looking at vulnerable
people in the southern region and it's a
critical important piece of work
so the issues that were identified at
that time were around insufficient
social housing to cater for demand
particularly pressure and invercargill
the second thing was around lack of
apartment style living and the Central
City for international students
obviously a different time now
and the third issue was around tension
between improving quality of housing
without negatively affecting housing
affordability
final point that they identified was
long average waiting times for
vulnerable people seeking housing
okay so now moving into the work that
we've completed in the last six to eight
months so there's six pieces of work
here and I'll just whip through the same
as before three or four slides per piece
of work
okay the first step that we undertook
was to talk with all of our uh manafinoa
and other ewe organizations and that's
just a snapshot of who
really complex issues
there's two slides of considerations
from a Maori point of view but some of
it was quite confronting to be honest
but I think it lined up with the wider
communities perspective as well
uh that concept about finangatanga you
know housing it's not just a house it's
about how people are together and how
their family groups connect is important
you're building communities not just
homes affordability
a lot of whanau feel like they've missed
the boat in terms of getting on the
property ladder and these issues of lack
of Housing and rentals which came up
very strongly across the other work
here's another slide
um yeah the overcrowding in homes was
connected to the type of homes we don't
have which I'll talk about in a moment
and I think a lot of the other things
here will come up
really positive around the future though
in terms of trying to find innovative
ways and solutions so really enjoyed
those conversations and I think this
will be the focus of what we look
forward
in terms of nahuifa in Pacifica
communities similar thoughts yeah
and we'll talk about the typology and
we'll talk about the quality of housing
coming up
and we'll just talk about some of those
unpacks of seasonal Workforce you know
which uh having a significant issue on
housing
was undertaken was from
and that was in regards to looking at
the Maori population of marihaku
17 of our population is Maori two-thirds
live within the invercargill city area
with Bluff having the highest population
there's been a decrease in the
population across the pandemic by 5.1
percent
so there were some interesting
statistics that came through from this
review
46 percent of Maori and that 30-34 age
group are in their own home and most the
highest group of people that own their
own home were in the 65 to 79 year old
so lower ownership rates across rural
regions and inner city areas of
invercargill as well which will connect
through to the rental conversation
in terms of renting affordability and
housing stability there are quite a few
statistics in here
so a third of whanau are likely spending
well above a third of the income on rent
which was higher than the The Wider
population
and nearly 40 percent of whanau lived in
rented homes
in terms of needs across social housing
yeah um so this will come through in a
moment we talk about social housing but
between 2016 and 2020 the housing wait
list doubled
and it's currently as of 2021 75 greater
than it was in 2016.
other issue here it's about the type of
housing that's required so a third of
all applicants indicated they need three
or more rooms so just because you've got
houses doesn't mean that it fits the
needs of people
uh just a little note here around the
data and statistics which is definitely
going to be something that comes out of
Beyond 25 because the data statistics
insights it's light across all aspects
of how we make decision making but a lot
of people don't register on the housing
register so there are areas that we know
anecdotally that there's issues but
they're not coming through in the
statistics and that's important because
that's how things are funded through
data and statistics
uh the last slide to do with this piece
of work is around housing quality so
one and four respondents said that they
lived in a damp dwelling and the survey
was undertaken in summer Early Autumn so
there was a thought that this would be
higher if you did it in winter
and dampen multi homes contribute to a
lot of serious illnesses and
hospitalizations of children
okay so the third piece of work that was
undertaken out of six was around we
talked to uh these stakeholders so two
workshops were undertaken and councilor
Campbell attended as well as counselor
so we really appreciated your
participation in that
uh so look they used a system called
investment logic mapping and that was
undertaken by rationale our main
Consultants who did a lot of this work
and there were two like I said so one
Workshop was based on social
transitional and emergency housing and
one was to talking to local developers
building firms real estate agents and
staff so quite two quite different Focus
points
so from those workshops there were four
common statements that crossed over all
people so the first one was around
planning rules sector capacity and cost
of Redevelopment are hampering the
construction of new homes and in
particular smaller homes
so they used examples of things like The
NPS for highly productive land will
probably limit development
um we've got things like different
planning rules with District planning
across the councils
um I won't go into too much details from
Shore Ian and
Jonathan will do that
um again
just around the different roles and
intensified housing
Etc
the second problem statement was around
a lack of availability or fit for
purpose rentals in social housing and
that's displacing whanau and local
people creating barriers for businesses
to grow
so they used some examples here around
the social social housing wait list
they talked about how few rental
properties there are in Southland
compared to nationally and I'll talk
about that in a moment
and they talked about the impact of
things like Airbnb on our very low
rental market but having an issue with
supply and demand which I'll talk about
in a second
the third problem statement was around
the fact that the existing housing stock
is old poor quality and lacks diversity
and this is resulting in a lack of
housing options and potentially poor
health outcomes
so we'll go through this in a second so
I won't talk too much because I'll show
you the full statistics
the last statement talked about how
limited housing choices are creating
stress around long-term housing options
for the Aging population of whanau
okay and that sort of Link back to that
piece of work that crying or Aura
undertook before
okay so the fourth one is still with me
we've only got three to go
okay so this was a large community
survey which went out to residents of
Southland so we had 861 respondents uh
November to December last year which is
a really good response rate and very
spread across the whole region
and we're quite happy with the
ethnicities as well as geography spread
but the age demographic was skewed
towards late middle aged adults
so it was interesting a third of
respondents had lived in their current
accommodation for over 10 years so just
keep this in mind when you see the
results
one in five respondents owned more than
one home
and most secondary homes were used for
rentals 51 followed by Holiday Homes 31
okay a couple of slides with some key
takeouts you can imagine there was lots
in the survey right the first one is
around the fact that there are large
gaps between the current housing stock
and the needs of different age groups in
the community
and they used an example of older age
groups so these people
prefer smaller attached homes closer to
home
particularly over 65s want to downsize
at some stage but they still want that
quality of life with a section to grow
vegetables but they also need to be
close to health care and other services
or have very good public transport that
allow connectivity
it was interesting because the survey
said they were less likely to move
within the next 10 years compared to
workers and students who indicated they
were more likely to want to shift
in terms of whether people wanted to
upsize or downsize their current
property over half of respondents said
they didn't intend to upsize or downsize
so more than half of respondents both
renters and homeowners said that they
did not intend to do this
younger people said that they wanted
larger sections that allowed them to
have backyard space and demand they
really wanted a variety in house prices
uh sizes sorry which made sense
and then there were a significant
differences across age groups
and again that over 65 wanted to
downsize
so it's not quite as simple solution to
just build a certain type of house and
you're going to have your problem solved
it's quite diverse across our whole
population
the other key takeout from this survey
was that 50 of respondents indicated
they wanted to move within the next 10
years and invercargill was the preferred
destination
and again this was skewed towards
younger workers and students
now we'll come back to that at the end
because there's some things about lack
of churn which will be interesting when
we look at this
okay so in summary there were three
issues from the survey affordability
and that and we'll talk about that too
because we are very affordable as a
region
but our local people have seen a
dramatic increase in house prices and
our incomes haven't kept up so for them
it's becoming less affordable
the second issue was around poor quality
and the third issue was around low
availability and we'll definitely talk
about that in a moment
right the second last piece before we go
into the the other results were around
the perspective from our employers
so we had 150 people businesses reply to
a survey really really good response
rate and quite detailed responses so
that's definitely an issue for our
businesses and then we followed up with
50 in-depth one-on-one conversations
so there was a mix of businesses who
were whose views you're going to see in
a moment uh so big ones from Alliance um
through two smaller mum and dad
operators motels in Te anau
and out of all the respondents 85 of
them said they're currently recruiting
staff with 75 of them saying they're
finding it really challenging to do so
so no surprises there were that 2.6 to 3
unemployment rate at the moment
okay so in terms of a couple of takeouts
of key findings just over half of all
businesses interviewed cited housing as
a challenge to recruitment 53 percent
of those who said that housing was not a
challenge many stated that their staff
already lived local
and in some areas such as Bluff
production line staff live locally so
the issue was to house new people to the
region who sometimes were existed
however the businesses are already onto
this and they're trying to find
innovative solutions because they can't
they realize they can't get staff if
they don't look at this issue of housing
so more than half of businesses
interviewed provide temporary housing
already to employees
so this does have an impact because they
are using airbnbs because there's not
enough commercial accommodation
we start to see some Trends there
a few businesses do provide long-term
accommodation and then of course
relocation costs are probably a given
for new roles now
so in terms of some other findings
employers said to us that limited choice
of housing was cited as a significant
barrier so it's not just having the
housing it's having the right type of
housing to meet the need of that
employee and they use one of them use an
example of Migrant workers who come to
Southland they're often looking for a
one or two bedroom furnished apartment
not a three-bedroom home with Gardens
and a yard to keep
and then they also noted increasing
costs of rents and lack of rentals for
executives families and young workers
and that was definitely a barrier come
through very often
and the third thing they talked about
was the quality of housing
and it was mentioned as being poor
so we're starting to see some key trends
here from all the different pieces of
research uh so a lot I won't go too much
into here but probably just to note that
we just pulled out based on location
um the businesses who were located there
you know what some of the key issues
were for invercargill was interesting
that you only had 14 out of 26
businesses that cited housing as an
issue however nine businesses said that
housing wasn't a challenge because a lot
of workers live with their parents young
kids so you just got to put it in
context
so the last piece of work was when we
looked through the Beyond 25 process at
tourism because the future tourism
recovery pathway will be based around
sustainability and air communities
surprise surprise but housing popped up
not surprise surprise okay so what we
did was we asked the consultant who was
angers and Associates to delve a bit
deeper into it
so what we've found here is that
residents particularly residents and
places where there is high tourism are
very aware that these implications on
accommodation and access to other
services we still positive compared to
the rest of New Zealand so it's not a
negative situation it's just a
heightened awareness that if you bring
more people in there's going to be more
pressure on existing resources
foreign
s from that piece of work was around low
density housings for all
legislation or regulatory Frameworks
around short-term accommodation or
Airbnb or peer-to-peer accommodation
and just talking about seasonal workers
because there are places throughout the
region who really have a Workforce
challenge in particular Tiana
okay radio so hopefully everybody's
still with me we're now just going to go
through the work that was done basically
understanding what our housing sector is
sorry even poor old Tom's heard this a
few times but even since we've done this
the some of the data's outside out of
date so that it does fluctuate because
it's a very volatile sector at the
moment
radio so invercargill has about 23 813
houses which is just over half of all of
the Region's houses
home ownership is very common in the
region 60 own their own home compared to
51 nationally
and you're about that 60 figure on
invercargill
and Southland there's not much variety
with houses compared to elsewhere so how
do we know that the housing stock is
dominated by medium-sized three-bedroom
homes which make up 53 of all of our
housing stock and this is compared to 43
nationally
and invercargill 54 of all of your
houses and 59 of bluff are three bedroom
homes so we'll talk about this more in a
second
uh then there's just a little bit there
about housing density
but there has been an increasing trend
for larger houses and sections
which backs up some of the other
feedback
so in terms of invercargo and Southland
we have older stock compared to the rest
of New Zealand
and Southlands 72 percent of our
dwellings were built prior to 1980 and
that's compared to 47 nationally and 37
percent in central otago
in terms of house price
again these figures are already out of
date because we've seen them come back a
bit but we are extremely affordable in
Southland you can still get on the
property ladder and own your own home
and at the time of this work we were 54
Below the New Zealand average of
purchasing a price
a house sorry however those house prices
are going up and there's been a big jump
in recent times
but this is still slower than the rest
of New Zealand so we've just got to
understand where we fit in a national
context
and the average household size has
remained pretty constant over time so
around 2.6 people
and so that basically says that our
demographic and societal change has has
stayed pretty pretty constant for the
last 15 years but that is projected to
change which we'll talk about soon
saying that a lot and I okay the other
factors around that there's lower growth
in new dwellings in Southland than the
rest of New Zealand so we've had growth
so 1.1 percent but that doesn't meet the
1.5 percent which New Zealand's head
in terms of consents we account for 0.9
of all residential consents in the
country it doesn't look like much but it
is considerable and invercargill City
all of the councils have seen a lot more
traffic or growth and processing
consents in the past year so if you look
at that figure down the left hand side
there in the cargo city looked at 277
consents where normally you would
approach this 100 to 200 and that's
consistent across the councils so that's
representing that growth and that that
we've seen recently
okay in terms of home ownership it is
becoming less achievable for
southlanders year
so there's ways that you can look at
comparing average house prices over
average yearly household income and
we're still very below the national
average so much lower here so it's
affordable
however we've had lower household
incomes than the rest of New Zealand so
what this means is that we've had a
sharp increase in house prices we've got
a higher proportion of low-income
households so home ownership is becoming
less unachievable in Southland for local
people that are already here so if that
makes sense
so from people out of the region very
affordable can come in for people in
Southland our household income rates
have not gone up as fast as the rest of
the country but the price of housing has
gone up really fast so the incomes
haven't been able to keep up with the
price increase
sorry if I didn't explain that
okay renting is very similar in terms of
we remember we only have 15 of all of
our housing stock in South and it's
available for long-term rent and that's
compared with 32 nationally
so that Gap has remained constant for
about 10 years and an invercargill 17 of
your housing stock is for long-term rent
Southland District Council the figure is
eight percent so they have significant
issues and a lot of that's related in
their tourism areas
uh it is definitely cheaper to rent in
Southland than the rest of New Zealand
so the average renters around that 340
per week which is about a third below
the average New Zealand price
however we have seen an acceleration in
rent growth
okay in terms of affordability here's
another economics lesson but if I go to
the last slide what's happening is that
rents are increasing faster than the
rest of New Zealand
and crumb growth is slower than the rest
of New Zealand so while the region is
more affordable for renting It's Quickly
becoming less affordable particularly
for people already in Southland
okay social housing
there is growing unaffordability of
housing in the region which is reflected
in the growth in social housing demand
so demand in Southland has grown quicker
than the rest of New Zealand and that's
because of a lot of things that a couple
of them is that there is a larger cohort
of low-income earning households
you've got limited rental supplies
remember those low numbers of rentals
and that is meaning there's
deteriorating housing affordability
the social housing wait list in
matahucki Southland has increased from
74 to 228 applicants between 2018 and
2022.
so that's a 200 increase compared to 170
nationally
so what are we doing to address that
unfortunately in Southland there's a
lower number of social houses to address
demand compared to the rest of New
Zealand and there's just a couple of
things there around the number of public
houses per 100 000 residents
is actively looking at providing new
houses which is awesome so currently
there's 446 kohanga Aura houses in the
region of which 402 are located in
invercargill
there are 24 homes currently under
construction and another 38 are being
investigated so that's great news and
that's definitely going to help however
I won't say however in addition there
are actually 52 other transitional
places run by other agencies such as a
marriage Salvation Army Etc
ICC obviously has your housing stock
which I believe is 215 and the latest
wait list is around 89.
similarly SDC has 69 Community houses
and there they've got a wait list of 42.
and that fluctuates around five people a
week
so just summarizing this bit of work so
while our house prices are lower than
the national average there's been a big
jump
we've got a larger cohort of low-income
earning households reflective of an
older and aging population
our household incomes have grown but
it's slower than the rest of New Zealand
there's a limited supply of rentals
and it's still cheaper to rent in
Southland than the rest of New Zealand
but it's worsening much faster than the
rest of the country
so this is meaning that people are
finding it more difficult to buy houses
as their income is not keeping Pace with
increasing house prices
as more households can't afford to buy a
house they look to rent
we already have a low number of rentals
in Southlands so increased demand means
that the rental Market's becoming very
crowded
so rents then go up due to increased
demand and then people struggle to pay
there you get the increase in Social
housing
okay all good
right okay so last bit
um is just uh some thoughts around what
all this means and thinking of the
future Supply
so look we've we've had a couple of
issues because a lot of air modeling was
on the third quarter of 2022 so one of
the outcomes of this work was that we
wanted to be able to say what is the
future Supply Demand on housing what
happened was that quarter four of 2022
was very different to what the economist
predicted so we've made the call to
actually redo all the modeling because
it's so different so we are due that
next week but that just means that this
stuff here isn't quite finalized yet
the modeling is extremely important
because Beyond 25 we'll look at probably
up to eight different scenarios for the
region around where the Ty closes or
stays open whether we get new Industries
like aquaculture or tourism grows or the
Southern Green hydrogen Etc so we've got
to really try to understand what that
means on our Workforce requirements as
well as housing Etc
okay so just to put it all out there at
the stage um there's just a few
limitations and there's this is an um a
criticism of air Consultants who have
been excellent really enjoyed working
with them but it's just acknowledging
that sometimes when you get data it
doesn't provide you the full solution
you've got to take it and put it in
context
first bit is around position of
equilibrium so what we're saying is that
when we started this we did not believe
we believed that there was a deficit in
terms of the number of houses that were
required but it's not a numbers game so
just keep that in mind Supply did not
equal demand so we can't start from that
point
um we think that there's some
conversation in here and it's not
rational's fault the data does not allow
adequate analysis but because of the age
of our housing stock we believe that
there's probably around 7 000 new houses
that are going to be required to be
built by 2015. if you assume that the
average useful life of a house is around
100 years
so that is going to be additional to new
builds and we haven't quite got that
through air modeling yet
uh and the other point is that the
data's out of date so quickly which is
what I've said before we're looking to
get it to remodeled so it's really hard
for economists to try to keep up at the
moment
um a couple of others we didn't find
some of the insights aligned with other
feedback from businesses property
developers and real estate agents you
know so that those business
insights you know around 53 of them were
saying that housing was a barrier you
know that's quite significant we can't
ignore that
and a lot of the modeling that
economists uses based on population and
they do think about other Industries but
what we're saying is that
um some of the population it could be
subdued because you're if you provide
the house people live in it and
population will go up but if you don't
you know so the people that model they
have to basically put a pig in the sand
and say right based on this scenario
this is what we're saying so it's not
wrong it's just you just gotta take it
with a grain salt
and that's probably what I just said
there is the fact that if you choose to
accept some of the modeling and you
don't have interventions you will get
what it says but if you do had things
happen that will change your long-term
output so pretty much this is the
challenge we've got with Beyond 25 is
there's so much change happening in the
short to medium term that you've got to
be very careful when you're looking at
long-term projections
okay so just a few last slides
um so look we really agree with their
Consultants around the fact that houses
we have do not currently meet the need
for population
so there's really large gaps between the
housing stock and the needs of different
age groups
and particularly the Aging population
the quality of housing was mentioned as
being poor and a key factor affecting
business they would recruit staff we
cannot ignore that
the second is around the fact that this
isn't about numbers the headline
shouldn't be we are so many houses short
it's not about numbers it's about how
our demographic may come so if you look
at this slide which Big's come up with
yesterday if we had lots of single older
folk they will need more houses we don't
have a lot of houses that they need now
but if you have lots of families they
need less houses so it's about how we
are as a community in a demographic
makeup that's really important
we are going to have more older people
the future any scenario is showing that
Southland already has a higher aging
population than other parts of the
country and all the projections will
show that it's part of the structural
aging
at occupancy levels are predicted to
drop remember I talked about before from
2.6 to 2.1 so that means you're going to
have less people
that are going to probably need more
houses
and our current houses again don't meet
our current needs so how are we going to
meet future populations needs
constraints around Supply are still
there so we have proof that we're not in
this position of equilibrium based on
feedback
uh we've got this this conversation
around
um it's across a sector so it's
executive housing it's housing for
social Community emergency it's housing
for our workers so it's not quite so
simple to go builds in houses here and
we're fixed
there's a lack of churn so what we mean
by this is that excuse the language but
people are stuck in houses because
there's not a choice of the the type of
house they want to go to so let's say my
mother lives in Gore she's in the three
bedroom family home she can't find a
suitable one or two bedroom house that's
warm close to town with her friends so
she's stuck in that family home that
could be freed up for families but it's
not
the second Point here is that because
we've got that extremely affordable
housing what it means is that when you
sell up or when you go to shift you
might not have as much Equity
um when from selling your house that
will allow you to go to other parts of
the country which have higher house
prices so that just means you could be
constrained by where you've got a choice
to live that makes sense
the other point here is that we don't
know much about the quality of our homes
but we can assume from being older so
remember 72 were built before 1980 and
we won't say that the climate's bad
because it's awesome but we are a colder
climate that you've got to say that
there's a concern there
and I think those statistics for kind of
Aura around Maori were quite confronting
around a 20 of Mary living in Maori
homes
and we just think that that needs to be
very carefully modeled and considered as
we look forward environment Southland
are looking to do this some of this work
linked to equality under their District
planning
and so we'll ensure that that's aligned
with this
okay we think that there could be more
pressure on the rental sector as more
rentals become short stay accommodation
so this may not be in invercargill so at
the moment the number of airbnbs or
to what we call short-term accommodation
is around four percent for Southland
like I said before it's higher 15 in
Tiana or Southern District
and for you guys and Gore it's only
about one percent
okay but remember you've got more houses
so you're not out of trouble uh but
what's happening is that tourism has
recovered very quickly and positively so
there's definitely demand there because
we still have a lack of commercial
accommodation throughout the region in
terms of hotels
so you'll know when we have a couple of
really good conferences in town we get
pretty booked out quickly in
invercargill and that was a problem we
had five years ago when we did the first
tourism plan that is still a challenge
but it's definitely been mitigated with
the langlands and distinction coming on
the market that's making a huge
difference
so we do have things like healthy homes
compliance coming in we've had feedback
that
uh
how do I say this politely I'm not
saying that this is happening but some
people could look at this that you
aren't under the residential tenancy act
airbnbs aren't included so they wouldn't
have to comply with the healthy homes
legislation and requirements so some
people might look at that and go right I
can there's demand for my property I can
put it on Airbnb I don't have to comply
and it might not be that I want to it
could be the fact they can't get a
builder the builders we've got huge
issues in the construction sector with
both accessing materials costs and staff
you know so there's a whole lot around
this
affordability it's crucial for air
region going forward like housing is a
selling point this is how we will get
people to live here
so we've got to still look at that
however we've just got to acknowledge
that for local people it's not quite as
affordable because again of that lower
income growth
and the last slide is around planning
and Regulation and there's already a lot
of conversation between the councils and
others around the role of that to enable
whatever decisions are made
um but again it's quite complex because
there's a lot coming at
us at once across lots of different
parts of
air sector
okay so that is that thank you for
staying awake hopefully that has
been informative
but I guess my key takeout is just for
you to see that it's complex that is why
we have gone across and talked to lots
of different areas because it's not one
easy solution
and it's changing quite a lot okay
thank you very much Bobby okay
councilors this is your chance to ask
Bobby questions and for us to have a
talk about housing needs so Tom I see
your hand indicator first and then
Mia Clark and then councilor Ludlow
thank you well first I mean I think it's
absolutely fantastic that we've got this
this theater
um refreshing actually be able to make
decisions based on you know up to date a
relatively up-to-date data servings a
great piece of what Bobby
um I think you I've got a comment and
there's a question at the end there I
promise
um
the I mean it seemed to me and you've
heard me make this comment before Bobby
that
um the population of invercargill
reached a peak in the mid-1980s and it
declined after that and it's gone up
again but it's still not quite reached
to Peak it was I think in 1984 I think
was a was a big number now there's
there's been any number of subdivisions
since then I don't know that there's
been that much demolition since then
so it does seem to me and I think your
data probably because this is less about
a shortage of houses is the wrong type
of house and their own quality of house
and and therefore if if we perhaps saw
this as you know uh something where it
is not going to be solved by most
subdivisions and building more million
dollar houses that is not going to solve
this problem it seems to me so so that
was a comment the question you know you
talked about needing an additional 7 000
houses because of the need to replace
the ill the the Aging stock
but then you talked about the fact that
we're predicting the occupancy rate will
fall and a quick arithmetic suggests
that's another five thousand so my
question is whether the 7000 includes
occupancy rate you're noting it does no
it doesn't it doesn't so so if those
numbers are right you would need twelve
thousand not seven thousand in that sort
of time frame and and to me it's you
know the question for us is how do we
make those the right kind of houses you
know not million dollar
you know three bedroom or even four
bedroom houses but much smaller you know
maybe infill type housing rather than
you know I mean you're an urgency would
you agree with that yeah so what I'd say
um Thomas can we just sort of wait till
next week to get the remodel figures
because what what I said there was that
we've just gone back with some quite
robust questions are there Consultants
to actually ask those questions and so
the next time we talk we will have clear
assumptions that figure includes that
that and at the moment we can't do that
so so it's not 12 000
um we don't know yet but I know the
thinking you're going along is exactly
where we went
thank you
okay Mia Clark
um you just some observations
observations probably um
I guess uh it's a great report but it
gets dated very quickly with the
movement we've got at the moment so
being a person with one of those second
homes that you refer to I can't tell you
the high house prices are dropping in
the cable
um certainly over the last three to six
months
um some were Plato but there's quite a
significant drop
um
and so that then begs the questions if
the incomes of the household incomes are
not dropping
surely that you'd think that would make
for greater affordability that's one
issue
the other issue is that having lived in
Auckland and
now living here
there's a different uh it's hard to
compare their family in comes and all
can some of the families that are there
will do more than one job
every member of the family contributes
to the overall cost of the mortgage
we're here we seem to be stuck in
I guess from 20 or 30 years ago where it
was so affordable here that you just
work 40 hours a week and that's all you
need to do but in fact I guess with the
level of late job vacancies but it does
beg the question is one why aren't some
families
to enhance their affordability or get a
better House of doing more than one job
now some would argue they shouldn't you
shouldn't have to
and why is our unemployment rate
especially the youth unemployment rate
as high as it is so I've extracted some
figures out of the um
and MSD recently and in the 18 to 24
year olds is about 900 people unemployed
themselves they're not sure that
includes those that are on the job
Readiness benefit which might be another
cluster again and about 30 of that
figure are Maori so um when you you know
when we look at some of the steps up
there around
the well-being of married families and
some of those damn homes
it's a bit of an indictment that we're a
third of our U7 unemployment rate is
married and yet we've got so many job
vacancies
so I guess that's a
some other factors that kick in that we
don't necessarily have the answers to
because it's quite a complex sort of
I mean it's easy to look at housing is
just housing without looking at the
other satio economic environment that
sits around them
so I guess that's my issue so the other
issue that hasn't come in which might
come in when your report come out is the
um escalating mortgage rates that have
gone from whatever was two point
something to about six point something
in the last six months and so while the
houses may not have gone up we'll be
dropping the ability to pay the mortgage
is was a huge issue
which probably wasn't there before
thanks to the reporting right so have
have you got a question for Bobby no no
just a reflection on some of those stats
I know how complex they're trying to put
together an overall picture
thank you
Council on upload similarly not a
question but an observation I guess
that's backed up by the report one of
the changes over the past 10 years is we
have a lot of residents who have that
second home and the second homes have
transitioned from being rentals to
Airbnb
um which is something that councils
and partnership with central government
would be able to address the report
pointed out that the airbnbs aren't
subject to the same healthy homes
regulations and that's where central
government could step in and and change
that it's also providing I guess a
a bit of return for the property owners
and that if you rent it out for two
nights it's pretty much the same if not
greater than what you get for a week's
rent but these
businesses are still not being charged
commercial rates and Council hasn't
addressed how we look at Airbnb because
it's not it started off as somebody who
might be hitting off overseas for for
two months but now there are homes that
are permanently up there and and really
they are operating as an investment
business and should be charged
commercial rates and and that way I mean
those those homeowners
um uh get some tax benefits anyway
and they're getting all the benefits
without
behaving like a business so that's
that's a fix that we can look at
thank you Darren uh pania uh morning's
more of um an observation and we know
that the money has statistics are really
not good especially around um
respiratory reviews and deaths but I
think you'll probably find that 20 of
Maori living in Quality Homes is pretty
low
in comparison to what we have here so
it's an abstract area
um I think the thing I've also took from
that is
you hit the nail on the Hedge when you
actually talked about low income earning
because the reality is people there love
to you for one year can actually afford
to
expand or look at Newcastle or Quality
House in any way of War
influx of people that come into this
region and purchase a quiet most of
their housing
so definitely we do have a shortage I
think what you presented today was
fantastic and I think we've got a lot of
work to do so thank you
yeah
councilor potential now thank you chair
look I actually do have some questions
just to break the trend
um
first question is sorry I arrived 10
minutes late but I'm looking at the May
2017 Southland community housing
strategy what what relationship does
this new one have with regards to that
so I miss something yes you did um so we
used that that was one of two three
pieces of work that were reflected on
looking backwards before okay so it's
good so it sets out some timelines in
that strategy we're now 2023 and I don't
how far have we move
in terms of reporting yeah and the
advice given
I'm just wondering have we yeah I could
maybe show you a bit more information I
put a couple of summary slides up no it
was just really looking at at it it
doesn't seem that we've moved much
in six years
okay so I'm one of my question is we've
got this new what we're talking about
today what are we going to be like when
the council sitting here in
2028-29 and we're gonna have another
Report with Statistics or are we going
to see some new houses I don't know it's
just a question because obviously we've
already had a go at this and the data
looks fantastic in this report
a year I don't see any houses anyway
that's that's blown by the other thing
is that looking at the local government
act it refers to
councils territorial authorities having
social policies now I
and our
I've searched everywhere in our policies
whatever strategies we don't seem to
have a social policy Dunedin has a
social housing strategy Christchurch has
a specific
um trust involved with these
now I guess this is not a question for
Bobby but I guess it's a question to any
Council officer who can answer why we
don't or where is our social
strategy that would incorporate social
housing because everyone else seems to
have one
where is ours that you can go to and it
outlines the Strategic Viewpoint that
the writers of this report back in 2017
would have placed into because obviously
if we want to do something we just can't
do it on a wing and a prayer we've got
to under the ACT
put it back onto some sort of strategy
or policy we have so can I is anyone
here can answer that where our policy is
saw setting up their trust as an option
for accessing income related yeah
there's obviously the
yeah so but just say dunedin's got a
strategy so just wondering can you able
to answer that really
yes so um
that's partly what the workshop this
afternoon is about
um You Might Recall at the time of the
last long-term plan that it was agreed
that as part of this long-term plan such
a strategy and policy would be developed
so that is part of the process that
would have that being triggered back in
May 2017
that's the process that we're in and
we've agreed to ah
I mean I I just it just really
it just scares me when you looking back
and nothing seems to be happening and
and a policy is one of those things that
we can refer back to
um yeah I'm just totally baffled
by
by the lack of
anything happening I just want to make a
comment because if you look at the
social determinants of Health which is
housing can I pull your mic forward
thanks just a reminder to everybody to
pull their mics so we we finished
answering why we don't I have a policy I
think
still in the com
ments so they're going to answer the
question I'll ask
John has got even further to add
and Erin okay appreciate it I don't know
why we don't have a policy that's the
question yes so but what I do want to
say is that if you look at the social
deterrence Health which have been around
for decades
you'll see that housing is always at the
top in the Forefront of our statistics
and
yeah so I'm really sort of like excited
that we're actually discussing this
today because I would agree that we do
need a social policy
or playing around this
Mia Clark did you want to comment on the
that particular Point yeah a couple of
points really um
just to go back to what Darren was
saying about the Airbnb stuff we should
we should signal with government there's
not a Level Playing Field
and I can tell you from my experience
that I probably had to put it about 15
000 to convert the house I bought second
house to make it Rental compliant if I'd
gone to Airbnb I wouldn't have put
anything in and I probably would have
doubled my income
um so that that was a good point that he
raised on the issue of the um having a
policy I mean I know we probably don't
have a policy but we need to have one
and the policy is not necessarily what
we're going to do directly but it's what
we're going to enable to happen so for
open sake it'll remind you that we
wouldn't step into the social services
area that kind of Aura currently sits in
that's that's fraud with problems but we
could certainly do something around the
Aged care which we already have an
investment in and expand that but more
importantly what we haven't discussed
today is how we bring new players into
the housing field so this is the private
sector we've got some colleagues down
the end that are going to give some
ideas about tiny houses but there are
other players that want to come into it
so our district planning is one of the
key things that we will need to have
around how we can free up land because
I've already had two people in the last
two weeks I've come to me and said that
they want to build in the Aged care area
but they can't find land to build on
so that's a real challenge for us as
Council to free up some of that
designation so that people can purchase
land and get some of these issues
resolved so it's not just us doing it
but there's a much wider picture but we
haven't enablement in just about all of
them if you think about it you know
they've all got to come to us for
consent and freeing our plan
thank you
so point out in 2019 of course the
previous council did take a decision
that Council saw a large part of its
role as an enabler as well as confirming
the decision that we were intending to
remain and and expand as we could our
own elderly housing provision look I I
just one other comment if you yeah Pony
is right every meal I talk to in the
country is facing the same issue and has
faced the same issue for the last 20
years
um they've all got issues it's a very
complex field probably one of the most
complex fields to work in because there
are big dollars in bulk and so they're
all struggling about their either
availability of housing the
affordability or the Aging stock which
they need to somehow replace going for
so it's not unique to us Nationwide
problem yeah I'll also point out that
part of what we discussed in 2019 and
wrote to the government about was
Council access to the income related
rent subsidy which for our own elderly
persons housing would make a great deal
of difference of course it's lgnz policy
that councils should be able to access
that that has not yet happened but it
may be part of their consideration again
as to front that issue again Erin did
you or Jonathan have a comment you
wanted to make at this point um it was
probably nice timing actually that
knobby went first because I guess
similarly along the lines of what he was
talking to we have seen the need for a
policy but we have seen it to date
around that piece that is core business
for us in terms of elderly housing so
similar to the ilm process that Bobby
spoke about going through with rationale
my team has done similar process around
aged care housing and there's a policy
currently being written up around
exactly that however we haven't stepped
into that space of whether or not
Council needs a policy as an enabler at
this stage
thank you councilor pottinger oh look it
was just um Aaron touched on elderly
housing now looking at that report back
in 2017.
um it talks about vulnerable people
now there is a difference isn't there um
there is a vulnerable does that does
that Encompass elderly or we got two
separate categories happening
here
um because reading the strategy from
2017 it talks about vulnerable people
their own housing units at one stage
um
because of the then low demand some of
our tenants did fit the younger disabled
vulnerable category and that Still
Remains the case it is certainly a
discussion point for us whether we
intend to continue that considering the
now high demand and wrong waiting list
but yes there certainly was a point
where invercargill units became used for
more than the elderly housing so when we
when we talk about it and and we don't
talk about elderly housing care do we
that's the wrong except the right way to
call it or is is the social housing a
better way to call it
part of the discussion
I mean like this is where policy policy
or something would would actually
clarify this
and you didn't want to be on the same
page definitely the criteria is for the
new entrances into elderly housing
however because we did have a lack of
applicants at one stage and we didn't
want those houses sitting empty they
were made available to other vulnerable
members of the community
there are still some of those tenants
and we haven't removed those as new
elderly tenants apply
but no new I've got a comment from Tom
and from Lemire
um I've got a comment and a question I
think the comment you know Earth focuses
I understand in the past has been an
elderly housing I think that should be a
focus going forward I know there was
there was some move away for that for a
particular reason a few years ago but
you know certainly you know when I think
about it I think I think the role the
council has for us to have should be in
um elderly housing in kangaroo are the
people who look more at the social
housing
see that but anyway that's just a
personal view the question I had
um to Bobby
was you know we talked a little bit
about Airbnb
um and I you know and it would be easy
it gets distracted and that and I think
we should think about you know whether
things like rates for example should be
different for Airbnb housings however
just to calibrate it Bobby
um I don't remember if you put the slide
up but I've certainly seen a slide that
says actually in invercargill that a
number of houses are Airbnb are so small
that it would make no difference at all
so I I don't think we see that as uh we
should see that as a you know any kind
of solution to this it might be the
right thing you do for all sorts of
reasons you know say thinking about the
race but it's not going to solve this
problem would that can you remind me the
numbers are involved
through the chair yeah you did
absolutely right Tom so uh four percent
of all of our housing stock across the
region is short-term accommodation it's
only two percent from memory one percent
two percent one percent in invercargill
however it's important that you look at
housing not by Council boundaries
because remember people live in one
Council area where it can another so
that interface between the two means
that what invercargill does or doesn't
do
um will impact other parts of the region
and that's certainly key feedback that
come out of all of the research
thanks for the comment Bobby Mia Clark
you're just a reflection for you Bobby
on the issue um at the research you've
done it it's extensive but the piece
that seems to be missing for me is the
um
research to the industry players who
might build houses that's the bit that
we don't have in the jigsaw puzzle and
those two people that came to me over
the last two weeks were both say and
I've heard this up north as well from
informatics and other sources that say
the major cost driver in the cities up
north is availability and cost of land
so some of the big councils organ
particular but now Christchurch as well
are looking at instead of every house
having to have an eighth of an acre
piece of land which costs three or four
hundred thousand dollars that we might
put four or five small houses onto that
same section which drops the cost and
allows players to come in knowing that
they can Target another area which is
the first Property Owners the ones that
are just coming to our city or the
migrants or the people who've got
changing circumstances that might want
to get into a cheaper house and free up
the family homes which we've got a whole
lot of so it would be helpful to know
you know when the tiny homes people talk
later on I'm going to ask them of their
experience of what are the roadblocks
that stop
um innovation in this area something new
as opposed to us just continue to build
three-bedroom homes
um so Bobby come through the chair yeah
really good comment um yeah so what I
would say is through the larger Beyond
25 piece of work there is extincts of
conversations happening with new
potential Industries because uh
Industries can only come here if they
can have Workforce that can live
somewhere that there's access to
Services infrastructure and enabling
environment so all that is being
considered as we look at the
opportunities so the modeling I talked
about before when I talked about eight
different scenarios and we're talking
about thinking of aquaculture what's the
impact on our Workforce households
required GDP as well as population so
once we get all that together we can
start to say well actually we don't
never have enough houses because some of
those new Industries need a lot at scale
and in certain places where it may not
be permitted or our land is available
so I think two two issues about that
when I see new players I wasn't
referring to new Industries I was
referring to new people that would come
into our environment who will build the
houses physically build it and what are
the roadblocks they've got about the one
or the two that approached me recently
just said I only need 16 hectares of
land we've got so much land in South and
how come I can't get there to build an
aged care facility which is a huge
demand with the Aging population
I guess the other issue is that I have
no doubt that the big players are going
to come through green hydrogen and
aquaculture will get houses because
they've got Deep Pockets and their
workers will earn good incomes so
they'll be able to pay five or six
hundred dollars a week for rent what
happens when those players come into our
equation is the social impact at the
bottom is horrible
and you start starting to head towards
where rotor is at but people just get
pushed out of the market
but certainly it'd be interesting to
have some research from some of the
current people that build houses to say
why aren't you building more what's the
roadblock is it District plan is it
spatial plans is it consenting is it
um I don't know is it we're encouraging
those three bedroom houses as opposed to
one or two bedroom houses or units
through the tier one final comment yeah
so we did talk to
um quite a range of I think Tom Hewitt
in that Hui uh property developers and
Builders and we did have some good
insights and it's all of what you've
said there it's quite a complex uh
situation from land availability through
to different consenting rules across
Council areas through to the fact that
some of them are constricted with growth
not having Workforce or costs of input
costs Etc so um yeah so we plan to
continue that and go back to those
people because we through the Beyond
2025 work there will be Jonathan sits on
the group for ICC in Tom's veins
significantly helpful we want to test
with those guys you know if we do this
does that help you know because we're
also conscious it's changing so
frequently you know so what they're
experiencing six months ago could be
quite different now
okay thank you Bobby so you're going to
have updated figures for us for our May
Workshop which is great and it's been
very interesting to have your
presentation today I know just one quick
question sorry
I mean I've been listening here so
social housing so because it encompasses
everybody
uh are we looking at social housing are
we or are we looking at targeted housing
for elderly for
um
disability I mean we've done some
development recently with Evie which I
won't disclose on an open decision
because it's commercially sensitive
but we've decided to initially expand
into the Aged care area specifically
because we know we've got an aging
population
and we know that too many elderly people
are sitting in large family homes where
there's no way out for them so if they
come out they don't meet our current
criteria to get into ours
they don't get into Congo War because
they've got too much Equity but they
don't have enough equity to get into
an aged care village where the the
buy-in price might be four or five
hundred thousand so we target that
because it's already kind of order doing
there
social and when they say social they
really mean low-income families that are
struggling can't afford housing all got
change circumstances yeah it's a fourth
year to work and can't get it or a staff
will tell you that if you try to
developer
social needs
um cluster of housing you just get
resentment everywhere everybody wants it
but nobody wants it in their Backpage
um so Tom and I have talked about that
as well but I suppose it looks at
affordable affordability and quality yep
well quite rightly so and and Kinder has
now identified if you look at some of
their plans going forward they're
building really good high-spec houses
because they know they can't afford to
be for wanted better Works creating
ghettos
um that they're putting in some extra
mix of money but again
you know potentially in South and half
the cost of a quality house is actually
the land
and this this mindset that we would have
a an eighth of an acre somewhere with
Gardens and areas to run a lot of
population don't want that
so we've got to think differently about
how we provide that or how we enable
that to happen I think is what I'm
saying so can I can I just say from the
chair
um perhaps to sum up
the workshop is a holistic one so we're
looking at the whole sure holistic
picture of housing strategy we're not
here just to discuss one small part of
it but to look at all the factors that
are building into our problem
um with as much information as we can
Garner and it's good that Bobby's
indicating there will be even more data
that will give us more comfort for our
May Workshop but certainly today was a
holistic discussion of all the factors
and I think we've raised a great deal of
them you could ask a holistic question
sure it really is it's a new question
I'm not really litigating anything
um but Bobby you know and Bex actually
what a a meeting
um two or three weeks ago which started
talking about the data and very quickly
morphed in a discussion a bit of
sleeping
and and I think you know being holistic
chair I think that's something that we
we need also to be thinking about as a
council because in Bobby my question you
would be whether we have any numbers at
all but what came across was that there
are a relatively a significant number of
people sleeping in bushes sleeping in
cars sleeping in Queen's Park
um you know and and there seems to be
when I when that discussion
you know came up there was an awful lot
of completely blank faces nobody's
anniated how you deal with that and I
think as a council that is part of that
holistic discussion that we need to have
okay if you've got any comment on that
yeah through the chair yeah that was a
definitely a quite a confronting
conversation we had Tom um the answer is
no we haven't clicked any data like that
through this process however working
with the community housing group are
fantastic so they are
it's gone but they're the owners of that
community housing strategy which looks
at vulnerable people and that's
certainly an area of focus for them
okay councilors this is a final
reflection on what you you commented on
before about us being but we need to be
holistic I think when we take a a
holistic view we end up where we were
back in 2017 or 2019 when you did your
secrets section 17 review we end up
identifying a problem that we just don't
have the tools to get the solutions and
I think one of the things that needs to
come out of what we're doing now through
Rhiannon and others is for us to know
what we can contribute and not be
sidetracked into what we can't
contribute and allow other players to
come but also to um to bring other
players into the field who are not
currently here that can help as well and
think differently about housing because
some of those stats up there were great
about
um what people actually want and you
know you talk about new migrants they
don't want a three-bedroom house with a
lawn demo they're just happy to have two
bedrooms thing to get on with life so
yeah that's that's indeed a point
um that that after the holistic
discussion we very much focus on what
the council is capable equipping and
able to do so on on that note counselors
how are you feeling about the need for a
five minute break or do you want to go
into our next presentation which is
uh Jonathan on-air Effectiveness report
would people like a five minute break
yeah seeing nods there so five minute
break and if people can can take the
five minutes as absolutely um gospel and
I will call you back in five minutes
thank you
thanks to those on live stream we will
be back
reconvene thank you for the live
streaming being back on we are
reconvening and uh Jonathan New Hair Day
presentation on the effectiveness report
to give us
cure everyone um so I'm Jonathan Shaw
I'm the interim group manager for
consents and compliance and before I
look forward
to bring Brighton
so I deal primarily with the resource
management act for Planning and Building
act for building obviously I'm fortunate
in the areas I operate in and that they
offer me a degree of black and white
with building our primary purpose is to
ensure that buildings are safe for
people to use obviously with planning
what we're looking to ensure is that
people are free to enjoy their
environment with as few adverse effects
as possible
um we don't uh generally distinguish
between social housing and housing
particularly with the building we just
keep it to housing we recognize
buildings but they must be safe for
their end user so I do have a foot in
that camp as well I mean obviously with
the district plan being our primary way
of implementing the RMA and setting the
rules and regulations for the district
there is the potential to feed in
Council and the community strategy
towards housing via that
so um with that in mind we commissioned
rationale to do an additional piece of
work for us and so the background to
this is uh listen to the conversation
around the table there's there's clearly
a direction being set by central
government
um
looking at the ways that people are now
living and how they predict that people
will live in the future
and they've introduced to our national
policy statements the first one is
National policy statement on Urban
Development how they believe that urban
areas will actually start to change and
develop
and obviously in partnership with that
we have the national policy statement on
high value soils
it's clear that the purpose of that is
to go hand in hand with Urban
Development and suggest that we now
start to come in and go up instead of
out and about as it were some centers
that will be more that will apply more
pressure in some senses than others we
are relatively Lucky in this area and
that it's not applying as high a degree
of pressure as say some of the main
centers we're also a third tier Council
some of you who were here in 2021 may
remember the paper that came up
regarding implementing some of the in
psud which was to remove car parking and
so if you're providing buildings you're
not necessarily required to provide car
parks for them other than accessible car
parks
um implications of that are obviously
quite strong um people are it's
anticipated people will need to live
differently and the car may not be such
a feature it has resulted in I've heard
anecdotal evidence of fist fights in
Hamilton over car parking spaces and
residential streets and front Gardens in
Auckland being torn up and turned into
concrete pads for parking so what we're
starting to see is a real shift in the
way we live and so one of the reasons
that we commissioned this additional
piece of work was because we wanted to
see how our current District plan was
set up to enable development
um over the coming years because as I
mentioned at the previous Workshop it's
a relatively young District plan it was
enacted in 2019 so we wanted to see get
a benchmark for how we're doing but also
we wanted to compare it alongside the
national policy statement for Urban
Development because central government
will assess how we deliver against that
not as quickly as 10 one cancels
obviously but we will be asked questions
so
um the report actually came in at the
the 11th Hour as we were preparing this
we only received it last week so we're
still unpicking ourselves it will be
made available to you after the
presentation what I've done is I've
drawn for my Slide the summary points
from an executive summary there is a
fair amount of information in there and
what it can uh similar to some of the
stuff that Bobby's touched on the uh the
information
the result the conclusions that they've
drawn have been placed on the
information we provided them some of it
in regard to infrastructure capacity was
provided uh at the last minute just
before Easter as well so it's based on
what our assumptions are and so if we if
we just deal with the points because I
don't want to linger on it for too long
because you probably will want some time
to digest the document later on
um so
well they've identified as dwelling
capacity and invercargill's been growing
slightly faster than the population
with an estimated 1 670 new dwellings
um
The Good the good thing is what they're
saying is on the current District plan
our total feasible capacity foreign
dwellings
and so we've got capacity for an
additional 6700 that's under current
District plan and also with the current
infrastructure as we understand it
um obviously they've got their growth
product projections
they're suggesting there will be a low
to medium scenario but they say that um
and the high scenario it would require
about five thousand Wellings and this is
by 2052 yet
so um
overall sufficiency in invercargill has
been assessed as being adequate for up
to the high scenario however I think the
sticking point and something that Bobby
identified in her presentation is we're
identified not necessarily the housing
types that
actually looking for they're going to
deliver what people want
um looked at sufficiency and Central
areas of invercargill again going back
to the National policy statement for
urban
development we anticipate who people
will need to come in and we will need to
start looking at Central City living and
mind for that and what their surveys
highlighted is that we're likely to need
an additional 800 dwellings um will
deter
entertain that
um so I think the good news is based on
the report what they're saying is that
yes we can accommodate it if the changes
will be required in order to accommodate
that
uh what I'll share with you um is the
two key changes that they've suggested
is that we
um reassess the district plan in regard
to medium density housing um it's been
mentioned already there's a 2 000 square
meter minimum lot size in order to
undertake medium density we haven't had
many developments who have taken
advantage of the medium
rarely because it's hard to acquire lot
sizes like that
um so there's some work to be done
around scoping that to see if that's
feasible one of the reasons that the
um the lot size has been set like that
is to try to prevent encroachment onto
neighboring Lots because if if you
imagine
medium density housing at the start
you are inevitably going to end up with
it in pockets and it's likely to
increase on people who have larger
sections and it's it's a significant
change it's a significant shift in the
way people are living and change can be
quite scary for a lot of people
um
so the other the other part that I have
also suggested is that we revisit the
Zoning for the Central City and
potentially rezone um couple of small
blocks to the north east I believe to
make them available for residential
housing
so that's that's I think that's probably
the Potted version of the effectiveness
report at this stage as I say it came in
quite last minute
so we're still unpicking the information
and as Bobby said we also do need to
look at the assumptions that have gone
into formulating it one of the things
that we carefully look at is are our
infrastructure assumptions great have we
got this Vision infrastructure to
service that number of the Wellings I'm
informed that we do but I'd like to be
sure about that
I think we can probably move on to the
next slide
please
so when we started uh formulating this
Workshop through my discussions with
Bobby and the work we've done together
um
I felt that it was probably best to
create this problem statement
um and certainly listening to the
conversations around the table this
morning I I think this I believe this
problem statement holds true but I'd be
certainly be interested to know if
anyone saw differently this day
because I think what you can what we can
take out of this is that essentially we
have an issue with um
potentially need more houses
built more quickly that are more
affordable but a better quality
and those are that's a real challenge
because essentially they're separate
directions
and I think that that
I think the problem statement and
identifying in that one actually informs
the the rest not only the rest of this
Workshop but what we're really talking
about which is strategy I don't think
there's anyone here that thinks we don't
have an issue with housing but it's what
our strategy will be moving forward and
how we anticipate people living into the
future and that's all that's going to be
really challenging
going back to what we're seeing is the
central government Direction on bringing
people in and out
that's radically different from what
we've known particularly down here in
Southland most people do is tend to
Aspire to the quarter acre section
potentially some people like even more
space or lifestyle blocks suggesting
that people come in and condense it's
going to be quite different
um The Experience
serendipitously enough Friends building
research Association for New Zealand
have just released their study on
densification and some of the cities
that are leading the church such as
Auckland are starting to hit problems
and one of the key things they're
defined is that the way it was laid out
which is actually similar to us
residential streets with lots of single
property on doesn't naturally lend
itself to medium density they're finding
the shift to medium density is becoming
quite problematic
all right so the with the problem
statement in mind and you may find it
useful to refer to it later on and can
we look at the next slide which is
cancel priorities
so this is really a discussion on
Council priorities for housing in the
district where the previous slide in in
mind
what is it that Council can actually do
to affect these problems what is it we
can do to influence more houses being
built in a
quicker rate and more and more
affordable and also better quality
and I think it's a really open question
what I will say is From perspective at
the building Act and the building code
it's actually quite simplistic houses
need to be safe for people to live in
Building Code as a bar is quite low it
doesn't take into account
it does have a nod to sustainability but
it doesn't take into account the
long-term savings from having
better quality housing in terms of the
heating having thermal mass that will
absorb heat in the day and then
reintroduce heat back in we're still
seeing very very low numbers of passive
houses I'm not even sure I've actually
seen a true passive house come across
for consenting an invercargill yet
invercar I know that Southland is a base
for making buildings from sips panels
structurally insulated panels
I I don't know that I've seen a sips
panel house consented an invercargill
either we're not seeing a real uptake in
the changes in technology that are
possible
however that's not to say they're not
out there we have had recent discussions
with someone who is looking at building
um
essentially a warehouse that will
manufacture hairs as they can do up to
12 on site
but they will still be standard timber
frame houses so there is a potential for
a lot of innovation to change this but
the building X probably not quite set up
for that
so I'm happy to take questions
okay so I've got Mia Clarke and Tom
so uh in councilor dumity so Jonathan I
just
one issue that seemed to be missing off
there for me was climate change and
please don't quote me as being a
strong advocate for climate change
issues but one of the things we learned
out of Auckland and the Hawke's Bay was
that
when you have normal intensity housing
which is not what you've been suggesting
um the runoff of storm water is
significantly higher so an example they
use an Auckland if you've got six houses
on the plot of land it has one driveway
in if you've got six houses each one has
their own driveway that minimizes the
ability of land to absorb excess water
which is one of the things that seems to
be happening up north it'll happen here
somewhere along the line I guess it was
just one reflection you asked a question
about um
about what could we do and we could
certainly free up land
which we can then Target certain types
of housing because we have control of it
when we sell our land we'll make it
available we can change the rules around
medium density
and we could encourage private sector
Developers and to go into certain parts
of the sectors that Bobby was talking
about before
and we can encourage tiny houses or the
sit type houses that are currently being
built more kipset houses which makes
them more affordable
but the other thing that was missing for
me is that Rhiannon and I and some
others did a survey recently about with
the 18 to 30 year olds quite an easy
exercise one although it took a little
bit of time to get their View and it
would be interesting to know their view
of where housing should be
because in the what Bobby was suggesting
there were lots of pockets of people but
it'd be interesting to know what that
younger groups see as their future are
they incident in a city I do they want a
big big plot going for do they want
lifestyle blocks
they'll want all of those but where's
the concentration for them and it'll be
helpful to know that so as rang you said
before we don't set up something go off
in the wrong direction
see
okay thank you looking acrossery Inn and
so that she can nod and tell you I can
do that I've got a I've got a comment
here from here yes it was indicated she
would like to say something sure
time to bring that in absolutely I'm
just from a youth's perspective and a
first home buyer myself to get in and
working with first home buyers as well
we see a lot of them wanting especially
at the price point with the kind order
and getting their grants every evening
here we say that a lot of us want to
utilize that especially if you don't
have family help getting in so watch
majority have been looking for
um as you know it's something that you
can develop a piece of land especially
if you have the skills to do up so the
quarter anchor sections are what they're
looking for maybe a lower quality house
but on that on their daycare
um and yeah around that price point but
I've found a lot of Youth myself
especially working Youth and just don't
know how to get in they don't know where
to start we've had a lot of workshops
one coming up tomorrow night from
invercargill
um invercargill yeah professionals and
just workshops on each how to get into
to the housing market as well
thank you
I'm sorry so what you're saying is it's
more important to youth to get in the
market as opposed to where they get in
the market oil location what a bit
Central or yeah they just want to get in
but don't actually know how to get in
thank you great okay
Jonathan you didn't uh so um just to
speak to your point man Nobby
um climate change yes she spotted my
deliberate mistake there um one of the
challenges is that both the building Act
and the resource management act were
constructed without necessarily
considering climate change they pre-date
it and what we do know is that the
proposed reform of the resource
management act will will feature that
missing third act which is the climate
change adaptation we anticipate that
we'll then start to put more constraints
on how we develop uh you raise the point
in regard to stormwater some of the
major centers that are doing medium
density are discovering that as they
start to spread out onto other Greenland
within their Center they're actually
taking away storm water retention um
we're starting to see more evidence of
localized flooding as a result so it's
something that we have to step through
very carefully
and that was the mention you you see
that you're in Trader when you start
thinking about going up as opposed to
spreading out yep right Tom
uh Jonathan
um the the numbers that you show in
terms of you know the quiet house
building over the next extra year
sometimes 10 years over it was but
um seemed a little bit lower than the
numbers that Bobby showed and it brought
to my mind the fact that you know
critically any
consideration of how many houses are
required as what we assume the
population is going to be and I know
that rationale
um at least in the early version I saw
either what assumed the population
decline right
which um and I think it would be equally
easy to argue that climate change if
anything is going to increase the
population as people come so that that
income assumption about you know what's
the population at invercargill going to
be in 10 years time you know drives
these numbers
and and therefore
um I guess the firstly the point I was
the question I was going to ask was
um whether these numbers are based on
rationales presumption of the population
decline
um and if they are whether it would be
sensible for Council to be thinking
about a range of numbers depended on you
know what population might be because I
think I could argue equally easily you
know population is going to increase
over the next decade particularly as a
consequence of climate change
I absolutely agree I've never been much
for crystal ball gazing
um rationale as I say are currently
presenting us a position at this point
in time I would certainly like to dig
deeper into it to understand that on the
surface it looks optimistic
um and they they are basing this on the
population remaining static um
certainly like to do
any proof
Ed or something a different outcome
essentially thanks Jonathan Grant I had
you yes thanks a few questions just on
that
last point of population static worded
what does demand for dwellings go up new
dwellings
again
um good question I I think what they're
saying when they when they indicate
static it will remain roughly the same
as it is
um people coming in people going out
this this is what they're predicting
over bear in mind this is up to 2052.
probably fair to say not quite static
they are they are pretty slow growth
they are predicting a degree of growth
but yes they anticipate it'll be slow
whether it will come so right okay yeah
thank you um because I think to Tom's
Point understanding the drivers of the
population growth
is really critical to how you establish
the demand in
the other thing I think we need to take
into account is what a question Realm
what percentage of the market is
um
are non-buyers so
um you know well they will be buyers but
probably they're supported by agencies
as opposed to their own Capital so
potentially elderly is elderly as
knobby's talk about and special needs be
their social need those sorts of things
but Norm you know people coming into the
market as Paris is outlined in starting
at the bottom and trying to grow their
wealth and move through the market
because I think that's really important
around
a decision that the council makes about
housing
needs to be determined around how do
they want to shape the market
and if you look at the likes of Rotorua
you know government stepped and tried to
shape the market around providing
housing and made an absolute
problem for
a lot of people so you know
invercargill's always been in my view of
your step-up Market where young people
can get in and then they can do just as
Paris as outlined and I don't think we
ever want to try and distort that
because that economic discipline is
really important
so what we need to ensure is that we
whatever we do we don't distort a market
but we equally cater for people that
perhaps
aren't able to be part of that market
and I'd really like to see the actual
numbers around how many how many there
how many people that is and then on the
basis of what your population is doing
because then I think you're really
crystallizing what we need to provide
and we can get a better look at it and
understand it and then partner with
people to provide it but not distort the
market because the risk here we're going
and we think we do it and then we
distort the market and all of a sudden
we've you know with apps you know
um
you know it wasted a lot of money
yeah I think potentially that will be
something to discuss when we look at the
district plan
um I understand the issues you're
raising that the district plans likely
to differentiate if we go back to the
problem statement and that we're able to
start to identify areas where we can
offer the different types of areas it's
big ones small ones
um including land packages yeah so and
to my point you know
you actually if you if you accept the
markers and move up Market by providing
more houses at the top end you naturally
get the moves through so you provide
more houses at the bottom end
you know so in in providing more Health
at the top indices you've got an
economic story that people want to
invest in so that's that's a good thing
you know so the dominant part thing
becomes an important piece of how we
meet the puzzle of housing whereas if we
just say oh we need cheap housing we're
a very different market and distorting
that market in a negative way one of the
challenges that we are facing is a real
lack of brain field development it's the
term that you refer to Bobby we're not
seeing brain field development
um I suspect that it's because it's
quite a quite a proposition to demolish
your existing home live without a house
for some period of time whilst you build
a
potentially a bigger or certainly a more
expensive house and that that will I
think that will start to create a
pressure point uh Bobby referred to the
useful life of a house as being a
hundred years it might come as a
surprise that under the building code uh
the durability period is 50 years at the
extreme and a lot of people probably
don't anticipate on renewing hairs and
stuff that quickly
yeah okay councilors
um from here without
um without wanting to make any decisions
there's probably
um two topics to discuss a bit further
the first is what would success look
like
if we're looking at Council priorities
and housing for
invercargill the region what would
success look like the second is what
roles can Council play
I'm wondering whether it is worth having
a five minute discussion with your
neighbor
and then us coming back with some
thoughts and perhaps and further
questions for Jonathan on on both that
point so what would success look like
um and what are the roles Council can
play so Council can be an advocate a
regulator a provider of housing
um and a partner to enable investment
so perhaps five minutes to talk with
your closest partner or I'm easy if you
want to make it a four and four
discussion that's up to yourselves
um and then we'll we'll come back with
some more thoughts and perhaps some more
questions for Jonathan
okay
[Music]
see
okay we're we're back on live stream
um there's been some really good
discussion there now I've asked Rhiannon
to do a bit of a recording session here
on the Whiteboard you'll see that I've
added the what would success light look
like in 2040 so sorry probably should
have said that when you went into the
discussion but we're sort of looking a
wee bit out here for what success would
look like and of course that's that's a
pretty high level discussion there and
then we've got that second discussion on
what role
those Council play so I suggest we um
take it one at a time what would success
look like in 2040 let's start at the
side of the table with them
Darren and Mia Clark and I think that
group became a foursome so you may want
to come back as a as a foursome with
your thoughts that looks awesome so I
guess if we're looking at long term
um that sort of period
um
what would success look like
um all our citizens have a healthy home
now this is invercargill and Bluff we're
talking about yeah yeah absolutely
there's affordability at the bottom end
of the market for
the parishes of this world to get onto
the housing ladder
being mindful that houses tend to
people tend to change house on average
about seven or eight every seven or
eight years so once you're on the ladder
you can
you can move
we've got some other ideas about what
council's role should be which is where
we focused
great okay anyone else in that group
it's good summary okay
so the other side of the table Tom your
so I guess her discussion mainly focused
on housing for the elderly
and therefore and we'll come to you know
a roll on that we'll get to the same
part of the question but the first part
of the question we saw the um objective
should be more successful like would be
a very low waiting list say sub 20.
there's a waiting list for elderly
housing that'd be a metric that we we
could track another comment that we made
around that is that we need to remember
that you know the the elderly I think is
a wave rather than a step
because you know we're talking here
about Baby Boomers and and you know Baby
Boomers in the next 20 or 30 years will
be replaced by a much lower
um a birthday group of elderly so I I
think if we were let's suppose
um this success again I guess you know
if we did have that bill to
um get to that point where we had a very
low waiting list then we'd emerge from
that era I think from you know if we did
a demographic analysis with a lot of
houses that might become available in
safer disabled or for because there
would no longer be that very much larger
larger elderly group because that wave
would have passed through and it's very
easy I think to do the demographic
analysis and that and you know see when
that would occur but certainly by 2040
we should be through the baby boomer
wave unfortunately
because I'm one of them
so from that from that threesome uh the
other bit I did is that in 2040 success
would be that we're not on our fifth
report
and things are actually happening
okay and Trish welcome back you were a
wee bit late but was there anything no
quite heck no okay Panera and Peter you
were having a yeah
discussion yeah good so we think that
our people that are bored and all raised
here on low incomes have a home that is
Affordable and warm even though we
support small Elderly Homes
and um and that we can't also make the
assumption that when we free these homes
up they're to help people there are no
incomes can actually afford them
you know so
it's sort of probably a combination of
that and it and we also support more
homes more hosts of disabilities and um
mental illness
so that might be two bedroom housing for
elderly might be apartments in the CBD
for single and young transient people
might be three or four bedroom house and
for large families and community housing
for Spiritual and mental mental needs so
that was us
okay and Peter yeah can I just add to
that and to what other people have said
uh we have a lot of elderly people
and larger homes with larger sections
some living alone
um we've got very little savings or
Investments they're actually asset rich
and cash poor
they haven't got the money if they did
sell up to go into the likes of their
Rowena Jackson or the bupas
um but if there were more modern smaller
suitable
smaller affordable for those people
I floated this way back in 2016 and it
just didn't go any further we had the
chance of buying up cuckoo coupon
they'll cycle track south of Macau which
accounts alone at the time
but it didn't go any further but if we
can get something like that for air
people
uh that will free up their current homes
and Paris mentioned it before
the a lot of them will be older they've
been there for 50 or 60 years these
people would free them up
for first-time buyers so that gives them
a chance to get onto the market
so we'd be achieving two things
if we could provide something smaller
and affordable for the elderly that went
out of their larger older homes
thank you they're running
um yeah look at just about what Peter
was saying I I'd have to disagree there
and I'm using my uh recently to see some
others example when she got a bit frail
for her house in the arrow Street three
bedroom house
um she managed to sell that
um on the open market and then that that
money funded her to go into Rowena
Jackson and and you go into the
purchasing scheme where you get back 80
percent after you pull out whatever and
and that that was a very clean
transition and then they used your
pension to to fund the ongoing so I
actually disagree that if an early
person does have an asset a free home
they are most at any time they can that
value will take them into one of those
other homes if they've got that that
behind them but there are people elderly
people that can't afford to live and had
have had to take out reverse mortgages
no it's the same thing
there are richer people in older homes
you just said your mother could afford
to but there are others that if they
sold up they've got to pay back the
reverse mortgage okay okay sorry no no
let's not get too much in here we're
just a Clarity of Essie Rich you can't
use that well I'm just clarifying if
you're asset Rich you actually own your
house if you have a reverse mortgage on
it you're actually technically not an
asset Rich so there is a slight
difference here so I just like to yeah
okay
to sum it up runny you've given one
example of
an elderly person who was able to make
that transition Peter's indicating that
there are others who can't I think that
that is quite a quite a fair summary
grant that was what you were going to
say as well yeah
yeah that there are there are different
experiences for different people who
perhaps in earlier times Life Choices
were made differently or things happened
income wise which is left
certain people in a situation where what
Peter is indicating is a fair comment
and what you're saying rangi there are
some who are able to make the
transitions also a fear comment Trish
did you have a just a comment
um moving on from what Peter's saying I
think sometimes it may be that people
those elderly people may prefer to live
in their communities where they are so
it may be a possibility of moving them
out of their houses building smaller
houses on the section and moving them
back so that it's still in their similar
community
just a thought rather than moving them
away from their Community it's something
perhaps we shall consider okay thanks
thanks for that
um Okay so
the only thing I'm probably slightly
surprised at was that no one
um indicated that success might look
like building both up and
and out at the spine I hope that's the
juice that we could build two-bedroom
housing for elderly apartments and CBD
for single young and transier people
[Music]
okay or people think that's a fair
summary of their success by
2040 let's move to the other
side there thanks Rihanna
what role can or does council play
so perhaps we can start sure again so
we've got a range of things
um that we would like to encourage more
medium intensity housing
um
I want to say that slowly so if you can
write that down um encourage transition
away from the elderly being in which is
what Tom raised being in three bedroom
homes so give them an alternative that's
affordable I'm not sure that market has
opened that at this stage
that we look to free up land we as in
Council free Upland for some of these
initiatives but we also look at the
zoning that we have in our district plan
to allow for other players to come into
the picture
um
we could look for initiatives like a
rate suspension for those that are
building currently building but yet have
an income from that building
so that encourages developers to come in
and
and the paris's suggestion early on that
um rate suspension could also apply to
people that are replacing old houses
with new so while they're going through
that exercise they could have someone
seem to take an old house off the market
and
potentially redo it up or knock it over
and put a new one on so that could be
helpful that's designed to encouraging
ground Fields development yep right okay
and the final thing we had was the issue
of the developer development of nodes
which is small Pockets sitting within
Parcels of land in and around the city
or certainly around summer so it's an
example was the one at Windsor that sits
in behind one of the commercial benches
here yeah three four five units small
piece of land right in the middle of a I
guess a mini CBD I guess where all the
facilities are there and that could
Target first entry or it could also
Target the Aged care secret as well
some that's
outside Tom are you
so we talked about four particular rules
um the the first one and we've already
talked to Berta a very active role in
building small houses for retirees
and you know just to calibrate that I
mean let's suppose we plan to double the
number of houses retirement houses that
that we have you get 200 approximately
um to build another 200 retirement
houses would probably cost us a bit the
same as a museum right so I mean that
calibrates I think for people we're not
talking she's a metaphor I've used
before we're not talking about climbing
Mount Everest we're talking about
climbing Bluff Hill
so um that was the first one second one
um you know a little bit less active but
certainly we should
be pressuring I think can get Aura and
central government to build more social
houses here
as Bobby should and her
um statistics we have about one-third
okay Capital pieces we've got about
one-third the number of social houses of
New Zealand as a whole and you know
that's a that's a consequence of central
government neglect frankly
and we should of all colors and we
should also it's also a consequence of
some early
early decisions to sell Alexis social
houses and not replace them Tom yeah
so that is a need and and you know
whatever that decision was We've Ended
up with one third of the number of
houses social houses and a per capita
basis that the rest of the country has
nothing less unacceptable and and a role
for Council because that's what we're
talking about should be to be applying
that pressure to Kanga Oran government
central government to try to improve
that substantially
such thing was
um about planning rules
and you know Jonathan has already talked
about that that are things that we can
do in that area to encourage for example
you know Central City intensification
you know building of Apartments
um it may even be that we need to free
up some land till that to happen that
may be another investment requirement
against a decision they cancel us
and the fourth thing was about animals I
just wrote this myself I never thought
about it
but if we're going to have Apartments
built they're going to have to be
builted in apartments aren't they and we
just don't have that sort of industry
and invercargill as I understand that I
don't think that's ever happened
Jonathan has it so how do we encourage
people they come in on a built-in basis
so then you're looking as well has
happened that no so everyone's at a 20
you know apartment block or 20 it would
need to be in a built-in basis and you
know that's just not an industry that we
have at the moment how do we encourage
that industry here
so there were there were the things that
we said but I'd but overlaying all of
that and this is Randy's point you know
we absolutely must have a strategy we
must for policy we must have a strategy
we must have a plan it's going to be
focused and we're going to be committed
to let delivering that can it just be
this discussion and then it goes away
for another five years
thanks Tom
Tom touch on this but I do have to agree
with what everyone has said but um just
I I would probably
um just add a create a simple stage by
stage process to get into to actually
get into the market
um but also a simple process and working
through building consents and if you
want to develop
because it's not a simple process
thank you Peter
yeah thank you just so much others have
said and you did mention yourself Madam
chair about
you're surprised that someone had a
mention of going upwards but Tom has
sincere about their Apartments
oh we've got a great piece of land at 64
Tay Street
um which is on the corner of the over
here with TR Stroud Jewelers were
um you could put a lot of Apartments
there
a lot I don't know what you put on the
ground floor there's probably enough
retailer around but you could go up now
this type of Apartments I've seen them
in Singapore and Japan they're very
successful over there
maybe it is an answer for us I don't
know thank you yeah look I just liked it
again
um it says what role it can cancel play
now
I think we've all talked about elderly
housing work we are on the same page
that that's our role and we need to
obviously encourage the whatever
government department is in charge of
social housing and work with them but
our role must be defined in our policy
that we are doing elderly housing and if
we are then why would we ever do a
two-story building because lifts add a
huge amount of money and I don't think
wheelchairs like stairs
um so that needs to and if you're going
to be building apartments that's not
again not us that is social housing good
intensive social housing but we've got
to be clear on our strategy what role
can Council play
and so that's we've got to be clear
otherwise we we're going to be like a
mad woman soon
Grant and then panya thank you
um just kind of understand
what if we provide 200 new homes for
elderly people what what do we do what
what does that model look like are we
owning the homes
yes well but not necessarily I mean it
you know there are other models where
somebody else could we could provide the
line somebody could build them on their
behalf including maybe government money
as well as money of others and we could
then listen back I mean you know the
various models that you could imagine I
mean obviously the go-to model as you
built you you build them an own number
it's not the only possibility no because
if you look at the model that the Ryman
Healthcare and so forth use around you
know there's a
isn't there's a clawback period that
lapses over a period of time
now one of the issues that people going
into those
um Arrangements struggle with is
actually they're giving away a lot of
equity yeah the cost of dying right so
in
you know I can see some headlines
perhaps on the papers in a few years
time around all the councils taking from
our elderly grandmother so I think well
however we construct that model we've
got to be conscious of how we'll be
judged around if we are thinking that
we're going to fund this through some
mixture of payment weekly or monthly and
a clawback on Capital
now that it's going to be perceived in
our community and I'm not sure it'll be
perceived as well as it is in a
commercial World which is the commercial
reality of the provision of that housing
so the construct of us building an uh
and having some sort of ownership model
within 200 houses
fine but let's be really clear on that
model needs to be stand the test of
judgment from our community around when
we're going to Grandma and saying no
actually we'll have 300 000 of the 500
000 you put in there because that's the
part of the commercial Arrangement that
you agreed to I think the principle
people sorry to answer the question but
I think I think the principle
assumption at the moment as well we're
really working in the people at Peters
talking the people who just don't have
equity in a house you know the
retirement don't evacuate or have a tiny
amount of equity simply don't have that
that money and we'll prevent we are
providing a parachute basically yeah a
soft Landing for for those folks but
there's other models where you could you
know that involve Equity transfer and so
forth but principally we're talking
about the people who simply can't afford
it any other way so so therefore you
know we
we are borrowing that money to build
that assets as an asset there's an equal
portion on a balance sheet of dead in in
an asset and you know we're just going
to make sure the rentals for one of the
better terms covers the position for
yeah or how much do other ratepayers
subsidize that exactly is where we have
to think thanks Grant Tom that's
obviously something to explore further
panya did you have a comment there and
I've got the media then I just
summarized social housing again because
I know it's not attractive and I know
that it's got stigma with it how do we
make it attractive it's in social
housing and because you've got to think
about the greatest need here within the
community within our communities
so if you put a social block this is
just
thinking out loud
within in the middle of Windsor I know
that that you know it would probably
cause some uproar but how do we change
people's mindsets it's a council around
social housing
okay how does the government so as a
response directly to that
we've already got a government
Department that does that we've also
heard from Bobby that we're about a
two-thirds down on what we should be
population
wise on social housing or something
around that figure if we get into that
area one it'll be a nightmare I can tell
you and secondly we give even more
incentive for the government would even
lessen to Southland by way of social
housing through Angora the other issue
that was the issue I was going to raise
which is what Grant and was referring to
there are other options than just the
equity stuff and the straight out we buy
there's nothing to stop us using some of
our land that we've got available to
encourage an aged care provided to come
in we could gift the land to the Aged
care person they then build more houses
than they need and they gift a percent
of those houses back to us as a direct
owner so we've put nothing in other than
freeing up the land we haven't built
them then we've got more rental stock
like we've got the moment that we can
have in the rental market much cheaper
than they can reach anywhere else
without without dissipating any
um any Equity they might have in their
lifestyle because one of the other
things that we sometimes Miss is that
we've got a unhealthy slice of marital
breakups and in that age group as well
and when that goes the acids or the
equity in any assets get split both ways
and so people can get left
um with a house with a whole lot of pool
level equity in it because they've had
to pay out
another part of the game we sometimes
miss him as well
thanks for that and grab
and Grant the best way to deal with
social housing is to look at cutting off
the need for it so Economic Development
yeah and and we've got to have an equal
measure a desire to cater for those that
aren't able to you know or need support
but equally we've got to drive other
parts of our business Economic
Development great self all that other
stuff because we've got to have Economic
Development and that's how you cut off
social need as you enhance people's
creative ability through education and
that sort of thing to generate wealth
rangi uh just a purely a question about
the current situation of where we are
without
elderly housing can
an elderly person one person on a
pension
afford to live in our one of our houses
they can we have a policy that it can be
no more than 30 percent
no cool I just needed to know that you
know obviously that clarifies a lot and
they get accommodation supplement as
well yeah yeah so that all works now I'm
just trying to you know work out how it
all fits in and works
okay anyone got any other questions or
Jonathan any comments sorry Tom for me
um and it goes to the problem statement
that's on the board
um I've never been picky about it but
that implies when you read it that
there's actually a stable population
that's simply moving through the stages
of the life
and we need to accommodate for that and
that's true but we've also got a very
different Popular Community as a
consequence of you know people who are
immigrating here who've got different
expectation with respect to housing so
you've got a you know greater tolerance
of desire for example for apartments you
know and and I think it would be useful
in that to try to capture that it's not
only catering for people moving through
you know the different life stages as
the fact that we as a community are
actually changing
so you're suggesting
um adding in recognition of air
increasingly diverse Community yeah some
wording like that yeah I mean thank you
Tom some some time ago I went to a
conference in Auckland and opposite
where I was staying there was about a
10-story building that were clearly one
bedroom apartments and when I look out
there in the daytime it looked like
every face coming back to me was Asian
so I went downstairs at one stage and
had to talk to some of the people that
were sitting outside the building I said
is this is this just your first stepping
stone to get onto the ladder oh no no
where we've come from this is the normal
living we're quite happy to live in
apartment blocks right in the middle
City don't need a car can go out for
nightlife
um it's cheap and affordable yeah so
we've got that demographic coming our
way I think yeah okay
thank you everyone okay Jonathan did you
have any other comments um yeah I'll
leave you a couple of three things
actually
um just to and try and inject a hint of
optimism into everything
um quick clarification for you I'm
counselor Dermody uh page 27 I've delved
into it so the growth predictions are
that if we remain roughly static we'll
need extra 600 houses between now and
2052 on the high end they're saying um
five thousand five and a half thousand
what they're essentially saying is that
we're covered either way with current
District plan and what we have available
I'll just draw your attention to the
maps at the rear of the room that were
put together by our GIS mapping team
they show uh residential vacant and bear
land the potentially available uh the
block
um to the lower right hand of the corner
of the big map is obviously to pull away
um and it's probably worth bearing in
mind that invercargill city council
actually adopted the plan change as
they're able to enable that that's 600
um potential houses sitting there and
obviously the map on the left is Bluff
and we can see there's some Pockets
there so
um what I really wanted to say is listen
to the conversation I think there's
there's some real optimism here the only
thing we're lacking is strategy I think
we're right on the cusp I mean it's
always the hardest part of any journey
is always coming overcoming the inertia
but I think that we're really close and
if I just have to do a really Shameless
plug something we discussed at the last
Workshop which is regional spatial
strategy that's that's what I see that
we're missing a spatial strategy for
invercargill that feeds into the
regional spatial strategy we know the
RMA reform is going to impose a regional
spatial strategy on us I I'm seriously
pushing um if there's if when you see me
you think of nothing other than my
irritating accent I'd like you to also
think of regional spatial strategy
because it's something that I'm pushing
really hard at the moment
not that above or below
Jonathan Rhiannon have you got anything
to add from your perspective
so we'll be able to build on your
thoughts um after lunch when we've got
some more opportunities to think about
council's role but now it might be
nice to welcome
our guests come and talk right thank you
now we've got Rebecca inshallah
who have been invited to give us a tiny
homes presentation and have both
traveled some distance to be here in
person
so they do have some slides and um
they've told me this slides are going to
be about 10 minutes and then we'll have
time for questions and uh and some
discussion so feel free to take things
from here both of you
thank you
um hi I'm Sharla um thank you to me
Clark for the invitation to come down
um so I'm going to kick things off and I
just thought I'd do a little intro of
who I am
um so I'm the director of collab
developments we run the tiny house Expo
a website called landshare and another
website called the tiny house hub so
what I'm going to share with you is just
a little bit about what we do and
certain stats that we've put together
through our event and our websites to
kind of give you some information on who
the tiny house Community are
foreign
so back in 2017
I actually founded the tiny house Expo
after starting my own tiny house Journey
uh we kicked off our first event with 70
attendees and now we are at roughly
around 10 000 attendees per event which
just shows how much growth we've had in
the industry
um it was also through this event that
we uh a group of us got together and we
founded the tiny house Association we
could see that there was a need to work
collectively together with government
agencies on the legal issues that we as
a community face around tiny homes
uh and also we identified that there
were a lot of people buying and building
tiny homes that don't own the land and
so we created land share which is a free
platform that connects tiny house owners
and landowners wishing to lease land
um to each other and it's been
hugely popular especially since the
interest rates have been going up we've
seen a huge demand of
um
homeowners leasing land in their
backyards to help offset the cost of the
mortgage increases that they're facing
and then the tiny house Hub we put
together a list of the top questions
people are asking about tiny house
living in New Zealand and we wrote a
series of free guides that cover all the
topics our biggest ones are the council
guide and the legislations that apply
and also a guide for landowners to guide
them through the legal things they need
to worry about because when you lease
land for a tiny house you're not
actually covered under the tenancy act
so we've put things in place to help
address that issue
um
and so according to stats from our
websites and our event so our biggest
demographic is actually 58 of our
community are age 45 or older
and we've got 61 percent of them are
female
our websites combined tracked 163
000 visitors annually we've got 12 000
followers on social media our social
media channels and we have 16 000 email
subscribers
um it just shows how big it's growing
and this growth has only been over the
last couple of years
and so next I'd like to introduce you to
the 10 personas that we've identified
that make up our community
um because quite often there's a big
misconception of who are going into tiny
homes and their reason for it
so first we have our single parents
usually there's been a marriage
separation and they're finding it is an
affordable way to to have a family home
on a single income
we have young professionals who are
trying to get into the property market
and using tiny houses as a stepping
stone into buying a traditional home
we have one of our biggest demographic
is their retiree couple and they are
selling the big family home buying or
building a tiny house to put on family
lands to be close to family free up
Equity to fund their retirement and
quite often they end up in motor homes
and spend summer months traveling around
New Zealand and the winter months at
home run family or if they have medical
issues that I've got a base to stay back
to for medical treatment
and then we also have
the downsizing solo retiree uh usually
they have had a bereavement or a
separation and they're facing retirement
on a single income and so they decide to
downsize to help fund the cost of their
retirement we've got the Modern Family
um we see people using them for ewe land
um we've had quite a few young ones DIY
building is an affordable step in we see
a lot of Travelers who travel overseas
six months a year in New Zealand six
months a year and it's a
affordable low maintenance secure home
they can lock up and leave we have a lot
of people as well do it for
environmental reasons and we see quite a
few investors using them for short-term
rentals
and so next to Rebecca will take over
Rebecca's our current chair of the
association
thank you Charlotte everyone I'm also
um
the director or owner of tiny house
builders I'm a builder's daughter so um
afraid it's in the blood and um it's
it's pretty great I've been involved in
tiny homes for the last seven years and
my goal is to have Chinese as a
permanent solution
um this is you saw them before this is
mum and dad they are currently traveling
around the south island and have been
here visiting your beautiful town with
their Caravan and going tiny has allowed
them to do that they live on my property
and we have a rural property in katikati
and my children love having mum and dad
they're the Grandy's and vice versa they
can help us with the property
um
this is one of my gorgeous clients
properties here and again just just
making note that you know tiny homes
aren't just
um big Shacks or cabins
um you know we're building a lot of
high-end homes that are homes not just
um trailer park Visions is is what some
people have so low running costs low
environmental impact and low maintenance
and it's a lifestyle people are really
looking for
um as mentioned in katsukati um there's
over 400 single occupant three and four
person dwellings that are tying up for
friendly homes which I I've heard you
speak already about that is a problem up
here is down here as well
um you know just looking at options like
the the option of maybe
um for example Bobby's mum putting a
tiny house on the backyard and leasing
the land being able to create some extra
income for her or moving mum into the
tiny house and leasing out the main
um
dwelling which doesn't currently
District plans don't allow for that very
easily because this is a new way of
living that people are wanting this is
an example of a aged care tiny home
development that has just recently been
approved for in Rotorua so just showing
you an example of how you know it
doesn't have to be a huge Community it
can be a normal residential land
um they can be consented on foundations
so come under the normal building code
but we're talking predominantly today
about tiny house on wheels that are a
temporary dwelling that people can park
in this kind of environment and have
that communal garden and Landscaping
availability
a lot of off-grid rural areas
um there's a demand for parking spots
for temporary housing you know game with
the district plans rural properties they
may have the main dwelling and then
another dwelling and then um that that's
it they may have eight Acres or more and
they're not allowed to add a permanent
Caravan style tiny house on Wheels just
doesn't comply so looking at that so we
know the greatest barrier facing tiny
homes in New Zealand is the legislation
and the legal inconsistencies and so we
as Association would like to work
towards creating standards and looking
at health district plans can allow for
Chinese as a way of living that people
want
um Unfortunately they don't fit neatly
into the um
into there's a regulatory gray area
between a building and a vehicle so just
Clarity around that
um is is where we're trying to work
towards
um
tiny house on Wheels versus and just
showing you some gorgeous shots because
this is actually this is the reality of
our tiny house dwellers
um this is a fixed permanent tiny house
and this is
um you know there's no no issue with
this kind of dwelling but this requires
land ownership and this is the issue
that we have as a community it's often a
tiny house without the land ownership
there's also issues with this style of a
tiny house on Wheels because the the
regulations and different councils
require that they can't live in a
vehicle for a certain amount of time or
requirements around how they connect
so um you know it is it's an option that
people are wanting
um and are doing and imagine that your
council's staff are already tied up with
dealing with um unfortunate tiny homes
that are coming in without ticking the
right boxes so we want to allow some
boxes for them to tick
foreign
house owners choose to lease land like I
say which is a cost can become costly
processed to it due to applying for the
resource consent and or paying
development fees so especially for those
who move frequently and having to lease
land each time the cost of repeating
this is can be a financial burden
so as a an association we are looking to
create a permit system where being able
to
a tiny house dweller could come into the
region and apply to council to say the
registration fee style like a vehicle
registration or a dog registration they
can move from Council to council and you
have that awareness of where they're
parked and that allows for that nomadic
lifestyle of tiny house living
we're seeing that some successes over in
Australia for the Australian tiny house
Association and also in America they've
implemented similar permit systems
um and so nationally we are
um talking to councils about being able
to bring this into a
um it's able and that enable housing in
Chinese and any regions
so we're open to questions oh just one
thing um we uh recently presented at
local government New Zealand Regional
and District sector meeting
um what we would like to do is to
facilitate any councils that want to
jump on board with us to form a special
National working group to look at this
approach of developing a permit system
together so yeah if you have any
questions but we'd love for you guys to
sign up to be part of this and if you
guys have any
um groups that you're working with on
this we'd love to be involved in the
discussion as well
thank you very much I've got questions
from Peter Trish and the Mia thank you
with your tiny homes what is the average
cost excluding land because the land
around the country varies the price of
land what's the average cost of a tiny
home great question and it does depend
on the Builder and what type of quality
they're building we're seeing them range
from around 180 000 write up some of my
super high end with everything in them
Furniture appliances trailer they just
bring in their clothes up to 250. so
there's a big range depending on the
quality as well we are seeing we do have
some of the eggs whether they're around
000 so at the lower Point around 65 and
up to what you're building yeah say 65
from 65 but a lot of the more high-end
ones that we've shown today are more 180
to 250 yeah
thank you very much so when you give
those figures are you talking about the
transportable or the fixed tiny house on
Wheels yeah yes okay
I'm talking on the fixed ones not Wheels
the permanent ones it it really varies
there's cabin Builders building
um consented dwellings as as cabins from
from very low numbers and then also
higher end so
um yeah but you wouldn't be going
anywhere you know 200 you would be
um top end yeah thank you thank you
Trish
um
when you showed us in Rotorua appeared
to be their own land is that correct no
so that one is a
um aged facility community group that
have purchased the land and the Chinese
and are then leasing back
right so but they they fixed those ones
are fixed so that's not that's a a way
that we could use that and how is it
that's a high density Zone yes so you
could do that
um but that's also that that is
something that's a very easy transition
again around what you're looking at but
the other thing is if council's got land
there's no reason you couldn't lease the
land to a tiny house to bring in and say
Here's your parking spot then you're not
paying for the buildings and you're not
being you know caught up with holding
aging stock as well so enabling that
option is the key so are you saying it's
like um little space that people can
release so they just come and pack their
part your home on that that's an option
that's an option yep but also same like
a rural property being able to do that
same thing on on a big big plot just
being able to park plug in with a
caravan plug
um treat and and deal with their gray
water and those are things that would
need to be discussed it depends on which
site a lot of them off-grid composting
toilet incinerating toilet so making
sure that they are self-sufficient and
not putting any load on Council services
and that is all solar as well so those
are real availabilities that that people
are doing now but the legislation
doesn't allow for thank you thank you
Mia Clark
well where do you go with all this
um
yeah look I got really excited when I
heard your last presentation and
unfortunately I made the mistake of
um Zoom going online to have a look at
you and now get heaps and heaps of
emails about tiny houses from all over
the world but it's a really interesting
field it really is
um I just think the the biggest block
and tell me otherwise is is the the
council or the local Authority rules and
regulations yes correct I mean if you
consider that I can take a
in New Zealand The Fairly substandard
motorhome with a blue sticker on the
back that I can probably get online
um and I can just about pay here two
dollar shop and you can park all over
the place and yet we we seem to restrict
the access of the tiny homes so some of
them are quite outstanding
um it seems to me that quite a few of
them have got wheels on it to get around
the the local bylaws I guess to call it
a vehicle as opposed to a
a dwelling we'll do a bit of words or a
building so it's still dwelling yep so
Western Bay District Council where where
we are so they still deem it as a
dwelling even though they it complies as
a vehicle yeah um but the wheels
essentially again because they don't own
the land so it's about being able to not
get the building consent because they
don't want the building consent with
that piece of land they're just going to
park on sure and I'm adding on to what
Peter said as well I guess when you look
at the costs of around about 200 grand
for a reasonable one and you could sell
one invercargill a house for
considerably 450. if you don't have to
buy the land you've got quarter million
dollars to sit in your back pocket you
probably don't need a bank because
you've already got the you've got them
already got the equity to buy it
what are the problems that you get with
the land ownership things I noticed and
I mean
um if you had any experience of people
struggling with it with the the lease or
have they been quite people been quite
accommodating uh
well
then she came about when I started
leasing land for my tiny house and had a
really awful experience and I didn't
realize until I was in that experience
Where I Stood legally which is what
happens to most people which is why we
have created the guides in the hub to
explain where you stand and you're not
covered under the tenancy Act and why
you need a detailed land lease agreement
and we worked with a law firm to produce
that agreement that people can get
through our website
even now I still get emails from people
in awful situations where it hasn't
worked out and other
the tiny houses on land the landowners
blocking access there's a disagreement
and they have to go through the courts
to try and solve it because
they're in a rock and a hard place so
we're trying as much as we can to
educate people and to produce a resource
they can use to help protect themselves
but again the current laws don't keep up
with that kind of situation it just
doesn't cover it yeah so if you've got
the wrong Wheels you can move the multi
yeah what happens to the permanent fixes
that you were talking about Rebecca
about
um I guess it'd be transportable if push
came to a squeeze while it's sitting on
land without wheels you could lift them
up absolutely yes
easily yes yep okay
thanks there got rangi and then Tom oh
thanks chair look um first of May
there's some new building code changes
um to permanent houses is that for a
permanent tiny home things like triple
glazing and six inch exterior walls is
that going to be compulsory the code
wasn't written for Tony so it's a bit of
a challenge already
um and the calculations will be more of
effect rather than the triple glazing
requirement it'll be looking at what
that how that complies in those zones
okay so you don't fall into that it is a
building consented tiny house on
foundations yes as a tiny house on
Wheels no no I'm talking about now the
ones on Foundation they will need to
comply if that is the requirement
although we are working with mbie at the
moment for alternative solutions to look
at being able to say well this isn't a
normal building this is a tiny house on
Wheels so the insulation calculations
need to be looked at differently for our
one and a half story steer Riser Heights
Etc are all um something that we're
working on with mbie yeah cool because
it doesn't make sense yeah it's going to
be smaller that's right yeah so yeah
it's already tiny sorry it is going to
be petite okay thanks Tom
so my question and maybe I just don't
get it but how is that tiny house and
wheels any different from a caravan at a
camper van it's a great question the the
it's not so much
um how it looks or feels it's actually
around the the purpose so the idea with
the Caravan is that it's mobile it's
more aerodynamic
um and that is where in lightweight
we're a tiny house on Wheels is more for
permanent living and built as close to
the building code as possible so sorry
again but as the as a proposite of
wheels just to bypass the planning rules
um it's to look at that as a vehicle
rather than a building so yes I think
the building if it was able to be placed
on as a
um as kids for example some some
Builders do don't put the wheels on they
just have it as a transportable
um then that but in majority of councils
as soon as it's on foundations it's a
building and needs a building consent
and the size range for a tiny home
generally or the biggest so we we stay
within the vehicle guidelines again so
that is 12 and a half meters maximum
including the drawbar
um and 4.2 off the ground while in
Transit 70 square meters basically yeah
as a well as a there will never be a
full two story so maybe 60. thank you
thank you Jonathan have you got any
comments you want to make about
tiny tiny homes in their invercargill
current
consent all right so yeah so certainly
um the area that I cover the regulatory
side and there's two distinct parts to
it so um got the district plan for
planning regulations uh our district
plan isn't currently set up to support
this as well as it could that's not to
say that if there were the desire from
the community and the cancer to change
it it can't be changed
um
so I I think that that would be a
question for Council to consider
um in regard to the building side of
things what I will say is that the
building Act and the building code we're
set up with enough discretion to
accommodate or do and I think to a
certain extent you're possibly owed an
apology by the building controls
Community because your journey should
never have been this hard to get to
where you are
it's just unfortunate that's how these
things transpire
I just wanted clarification District
plan doesn't prevent them
but it doesn't support them you're right
it basically it looks at in terms of
dwellings
um and I I think in some ways you
devalue your product by referring to it
as a tiny home a home is a home and a
home is a good thing regardless of its
size so the way that the district plan
would interpret it it would see that as
one dwelling and our district plan
currently requires one dwelling per lot
so essentially it would help you Paris
something that you'd be able to have
your quarter acre section with a smaller
home on it
yeah
just a clarification for Jonathan so you
see quite a few houses have a granny
flat out the back
and that could be deemed a tiny home
they don't pay separate rates for that
Granny flat
out the back so you know it's plumbed is
so the district plan supports secondary
residence that's used in association
with the primary one
Extinction it makes okay it's an
association so there's no reason why
if it was an association
same thing if you're living with you um
parents yeah it's all fine it's when it
becomes separate families and they're
plumbed in then and needs a separate
title does the land need a separate
total and then it's a separate rateable
unit
yep so currently the district plan will
only support one one unit per lot you
you can have a flat attached or not but
it needs to be used in connection with
the primary unit okay
Tom so it isn't the case just further to
arrange his question although you can
have a a granny flood it can it be
completely self-contained it can't have
a kitchen in it for example if it's on
the same yes what
so providing it to use in association
with a primary unit that's fine it can
be Standalone it can have a kitchen and
this goes back to the point that I've
just built one in a specific requirement
that I could not put in a kitchen
I'd be happy to be approached to discuss
it the pressure I've got I've got Trish
and then I've got a comment from
Patricia Christie I've got some years
I've just got a question about
um what happens if so if the if the if
your parents sell the land
sorry if you sell the land sorry what
happens to your parents so that's a
discussion that we have and Mum and Dad
have said prior if we were to move they
would bring the tiny to somewhere we
they would either lease land if we
decided to go apartment living or leave
the country that but otherwise they'll
come with us and we will find a property
that works for them but you know that's
in the best world as sure yeah you know
it may well be it doesn't work that way
you know and it's possible that the
people who own the top who lease the
Tony house on the land are disadvantaged
not necessarily because they'll be
creating an income from it so they might
say okay you're going to be able to
lease a year and we're going to have
confirmed site for you and they may know
that in a year's time just like you
would a normal rental property right
that you may need to move and you know
your rental property you're in the same
position right so an effect it's like a
rental property correct it makes sense
yes thank you thank you although you're
only supplying the land yes yeah and
potentially the service connection yes
thank you Patricia you had a comment to
make
um this was probably more in relation to
councilor pottinger's comment about
rating
um rating for services tends to be on
separately used and inhabited portions
of a rating unit so in some cases where
we have granny flats that are separately
used and inhabited typically connected
to water they do incur additional water
charges and all those as a relation to
that in relation to a tiny home because
it's probably not connected there's
probably no additional rates ah so the
granny flat connected at the back of the
house
it could be considered as separately
used and inhabitable portion of a
property even though it's your granny
okay
it was okay I just make a comment on
that too as a granny flat you will be
getting the building consent paying the
Geotech reports designers engineers and
most likely your development
contributions as a tiny house you're
literally parking it there so it is a
quite a difference in cost for the
dweller
in the landowner I just oh can I say one
thing too um like with Rebecca's
situation uh if she's brought you know
the lifestyle block which was a
three-bedroom home and then they've gone
through the consent process and put the
tiny on they've raised the value of that
property and so
it means that uh quite often it's not
achievable for first-time buyers coming
into the market because it's now a lot
higher value property where if you know
it was a tiny house on wheels that
didn't need to go through this same
consent process to be titled To That
land
if the situation changes they could move
the tiny house and it's still a three
bedroom property and it's at a lower
value which you know is more achievable
for people trying to get into the market
so it allows flexibility depending on
the life style or the
stage people are at in their lives
there's flexibility around that which
there currently isn't if you have to fix
fix it entitle it to the land
thank you for that clarification now
we're just on 12 o'clock and Mia Clark
you might be the last just a quick one
for the the issue that ring you raised
before about the granny fat type
scenario and we had a case
last year
um where
um
a landowner had it Mom and Dad
grandparents living on a secondary
uh house out here did have all the
facilities
um
they then passed away and so the LA the
primary land owner rented that out and I
think Council just turned a blind eye to
that but then the primary ones decided
to relocate to Dunedin when they went
they put on the market said you know
beautiful home here with rental
potential or ports no no no no rental
potential so they got unstuck with that
where they had to re-classify that
secondary part of the land with the
second house on it as a separate plot so
it is fraught with problems you do need
advice for getting into this sort of you
know that's all I can say
well it's an exciting area okay thank
you for that brought with problems
probably sums up a lot of the housing
issue
um thank you very much to the two of you
for your presentation and the Very
clear answers to questions it's been a
very interesting presentation thanks for
having us yeah thank you thank you for
traveling
I've been traveling to many homes we
flew
counselors remarkably we have reached 12
o'clock and unless anybody is going to
indicate that they have anything further
they would like to add to the discussion
at this point
I will call this part of
the workshop to a close and say thank
you to those who have been in attendance
on our live stream
and